the
9269th meeting of the Security Council
is called to order
the provisional agenda for this meeting
is maintenance of peace and security of
Ukraine
the representative of the Russian
Federation has asked for the floor to
make a statement
Mr President
to just say a few words regarding a
point of order
we would like to ask you to please
clarify
what is the basis that you are proposing
to give the floor to the ministry of
Universe of Ukraine and to give them the
floor before members of the council
speak
we have nothing against his statement
but the council
has its rules
which were established long before Malta
became president in the security Council
became a member rather of uh the
security Council and me miss you Mr
President could at least provide me with
the answer to my question thank you
I I take note of the points raised by
the representative of the Russian
Federation
this debate is being held on the
one-year anniversary since the beginning
of the war in Ukraine
and the presidency sees value in
allowing ukrainians foreign minister
take the floor before all the other
members of the Council on this occasion
as per rule 33 of note 507.
the representative of the Russian
Federation has asked for the floor to
make a statement I give them the floor
Mr President
um I would like to just warn you that
the moment you put the gavel down
thus formalizing your decision you will
create an egregious precedent where
representatives of Ukraine in the
council are given the kind of privilege
that is denied to the representative of
others let me just give you a specific
example from recent practice uh the uh
meeting on car and then it towards the
first of February this year this year
the Minister of Foreign Affairs of karma
Miss Valerie spoke after members of the
Council on the 27th of February we had a
meeting on Mali and the Minister of
Foreign Affairs of that country Mr Abu
also took the flow after members of the
Council on the 11th of January we had a
meeting on Colombia and the vice
president of Colombia and let me
underscore this not a minister but a the
vice president Mr Miss Mino spoke after
members of the Council on the 24th of
January this year we had a meeting on
Haiti and the Minister of Foreign
Affairs of the Dominican Republic Mr
Alvarez Gil took the floor after all
members of the council have spoken
and he also spoke after all Security
Council meetings members at the meeting
of Haiti later on in the year and I
continue can continue on with the list
if we're talking about President well Mr
culeba took the floor on the 22nd of
September 2022 and he spoke after all
members of the council there hasn't been
a single case a single proposal from
Western delegation to give the floor to
representative of African Latin American
or any other countries other than
Ukraine to give to give them the floor
and meetings which directly affects them
that they speak before members of the
council can you uh see what your
decision to provide Mr culeba with a
privilege privileged right to speak at
the beginning of of the meeting in the
eyes of the world once again we have
nothing against a statement that will be
made by Mr gulabo searched and ready to
listen to it but this has been done
strictly in line with the practice we
have when the delegation under rule 37
speak after the members of the council
what we're witnessing today is yet
another attempt to give certain rights
to a group of the country whereas you as
a representative of the golden billion
give preference to Ukraine just because
that she is a part of your geopolitical
project it turns out that it would seem
that the problems of the rest of the
world are of no concern to you the same
applies to the unprecedented number of
delegations I'm invited today under rule
37 12 EU country in addition to the high
representative Joseph Burrell it's clear
that all of these countries who have the
same EU position dictated from Brussels
will bring in no added value to the
discussion
no added value such an approach devalues
the value of the discussion and Strikes
against the reputation of the council
our British colleagues have already
joined history as a bad faith president
of the council where they rejected our
request for a special emergency session
of the council which was unprecedented
and we regret the fact that the Maltese
presidency time and time again ignored
the rules of procedure of the council
and thus Place its own National position
the position of EU above its
responsibility of presidency presidency
which is supposed to make sure that the
procedures are upheld and be impartial
we must acknowledge that Malta is not a
a is not carrying out this task and this
confirms us in our opinion that there is
no added value to expand the council
with Western countries because you are
turning the council into through your in
your own instrument I thank you
once again I I take note of the points
raised by the representative of the
Russian Federation
may I also remind that for instance the
foreign minister of Serbia spoke before
the security Council Members at least
twice in the last two meetings on unmik
and with regard to the list of speakers
under rule 37
the presidency took note of the fact
that all these requests came from
foreign ministers who took the time to
travel to New York to be at the United
Nations on this anniversary
this clearly indicates that they feel
that their countries have been and are
still being directly impacted by this
war
the agenda is adopted
I would like to warmly welcome the
Secretary General and the distinguished
ministers and other high-level
Representatives
your presence today underscores the
importance of the subject matter on the
discussion
in accordance with rule 37 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite the representatives of Croatia
Czech Estonia Germany Hungary Italy
Latvia Netherlands North Macedonia
Poland Republic of Moldova Romania
Slovakia Spain and Ukraine to
participate in this meeting
it is so decided
in accordance with rule 39 of the
council's provisional rules of procedure
I invite his Excellency Mr Jose Burrell
High representative of the European
Union for foreign affairs and security
policy to participate in this meeting
so decided
the security Council will now begin its
consideration of item 2 of the agenda
and I now give the floor to the
Secretary General his Excellency Mr
Antonio Gutierrez
it's the president's excellencies
the purposes and principles embedded in
the United Nations Charter are not a
matter of convenience
they are not merely words on paper
they are at the core of Who We Are
and they reflect the driving mission of
our United Nations
and they exist precisely to address any
grievance whatever it may be
one year ago I sat in this Council and
urged and I quote
in the name of humanity do not allow to
start in Europe
what could be the worst war since the
beginning of the century
with consequences not only devastating
for Ukraine not only tragic for the
Russian Federation
but with an impact we cannot even
foresee in relation to the consequences
for the global economy
end of quote
I said then that we must give peace a
chance but peace has had no chance
War has ruled the day
the Russian invasion of Ukraine is a
blatant violation of the United Nations
Charter and international law
it has Unleashed widespread deaths
destruction and displacement
attacks on civilians and civilian
infrastructure have caused many
casualties and terrible sufferings
the office of the eye commissioner for
human rights has documented dozens of
cases of conflict-related sexual
violence against men women and girls
and serious violations of international
humanitarian and human rights law
against prisoners of war and hundreds of
cases of enforced disappearances and
arbitrary detentions of civilians were
also documented
Mr President life is a living hell for
the people of Ukraine
an estimated 17.6 million people nearly
40 percent of the population of Ukraine
require humanitarian assistance and
protection
the crisis has erased 30 percent of free
war jobs
will program estimates that nearly 40
percent of ukrainians are unable to
afford or access enough food
and water sparked a displacement crisis
not seen in Europe in decades
more than 8 million Ukrainian refugees
have been recorded across Europe
in addition to an estimate is 5.4
million who have been internally
displaced
more than half of all Ukrainian children
have been forced from their homes with
unaccompetent separated children facing
grave risks of violence abuse and
exploitation
vital infrastructure is under Fire Water
Energy and heating systems have been
destroyed in the depths of a freezing
winter
's organization has verified over 700
attacks on Healthcare facilities and
More Than 3 000 schools and colleges
have been damaged or destroyed
millions of students ever that education
severely disrupted
less measurable but not less important
is a devastating impact of months of
displacement and bombardment on the
mental health of ukrainians
nearly 10 million people including 7.8
million children are at risk of acute
post-traumatic stress disorder
and make no mistake the Russian
Federation is also Suffering The Deadly
consequences
Mr President
we need peace
peace in line with the United Nations
Charter and international law
as we work for peace we will continue
calling for action on many fronts
protection of civilians must remain the
top priority attacks on civilians and
civilian infrastructure must stop
the use of explosive weapons with wide
area effects in populated areas in towns
cities and Villages must end safe and
unimpeded humanitarian access for
life-saving assistance
must be insured we must also invest in
Ukraine's recovery and reconstruction
add the request of the Ukrainian
government and on behalf of the United
Nations system the United Nations
development program is a co-leading and
assessment of damage to energy
infrastructure jointly with the World
Bank Mr President
since the start of the war the
international atomic energy agency has
supported Ukraine to ensure the safety
and security of its 15 operating
reactors at four nuclear plants
including Europe's largest nuclear power
plant in the operation
we continue to urge all parties to
swiftly agree and Implement a nuclear
Safety and Security protection Zone at
this operation nuclear power plant to
avoid a serious accident with
potentially disastrous consequences
barely veiled threats to use nuclear
weapons in the context of the conflict
have spiked nuclear risks to levels not
seen since the darkest days of the Cold
War these threats are unacceptable
progress continues to be made under the
Black Sea grain initiative an agreements
brokered with the parties by the United
Nations and the government of Turkey
more than 20 million metric tons of
foodstuffs have now been safely
reconnected to Global Supply chains on
more than 700 ships helping to bring
down prices around the world
I want to underscore the importance of
all parties remaining engaged in these
initiatives and related our call for it
to be extended Beyond March 2023
and the United Nations is firmly
committed to working to remove remaining
obstacles to Russian food and fertilizer
exports including ammonia
these exports are essential to our
broader efforts to bring down prices and
these food insecurity around the globe
both efforts demonstrate that
International cooperation is essential
valuable and possible even in the midst
of conflict
Mr President over the past year this
Council has held more than 40 debates on
Ukraine
the guns are talking now but in the end
we know we all know that the past of
diplomacy and accountability is the road
to a just and sustainable peace
peace in line with un Charter
international law and yesterday's
resolution of the general assembly
we must prevent further escalation
we must all encourage every meaningful
effort to end the Bloodshed and at long
last Give Peace a chance thank you
I thank the Secretary General for his
briefing
and I now give the floor to his
Excellency Mr dimitro culeba Minister of
Foreign Affairs of Ukraine
Mr President
distinguished members of the security
Council
Secretary General
first of all I would like to thank the
presidency of Malta for convening this
important meeting
the general assembly has just passed a
resolution on the principles of
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
141 member states took the site of the
U.N Charter
while seven took the side of Russia
no additional explanations are required
here
the resolution follows the logic of
President zielinski's peace formula
the goal of this 10 point plan is to
restore respect for Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
within its internationally recognized
borders
in full compliance with the UN Charter
that we all have committed to respect
and uphold
to make it short
the goal of the plan is to get Russia
out of Ukraine and make the world a
safer place
obviously any new peace proposals should
now be aligned with demands set forth by
the resolution
we invite all countries from every
corner of the world to facilitate
implementation of the resolution and the
peace formula
we need to act jointly and quickly
to ensure nuclear Safety and Security
by forcing Russia to withdraw from the
illegally occupied zaporation nuclear
power plant and stopping missile attacks
that endanger nuclear power plants
across the territory of Ukraine
to avoid the threat of hunger
by furthering the Black Sea grain
initiative and countering Russian
efforts to undermine it as well as by
developing our grain from Ukraine
initiative
to prevent an energy crisis which will
require the cessation of Russian missile
Terror against critical infrastructure
of Ukraine
to protect the environment as the
Russian shelling that burned millions of
hectares of Ukrainian forests threatens
our efforts to counter global warming
but first and foremost
people must be saved
their lives and their rights are at the
center of our struggle for peace
the magnitude of the humanitarian crisis
brought on by Russia's aggression
against Ukraine cannot be overstated
I would like to highlight here only one
of numerous horrendous facts
Russia
is now implementing in Ukraine
probably the largest instance of
state-sponsored kidnapping of children
in history of our modern world
dear members of the council
Ukraine will resist as it has done so
far
and Ukraine will win
Putin is going to lose much sooner than
he thinks
here is what Russian officials and
servicemen have to know
you think you would get away with what
you did
no
you will end up on trials
you will be testifying how strongly you
will opposed to the aggression
and how you just followed orders
you think that the world will get tired
of supporting Ukraine
the support will only get stronger
you think that Ukraine will eventually
Tire of Defending itself
the more the more and the longer you
will keep attacking Ukraine the more
resolved we will have and the more
humiliating your defeat will be
your colleagues Russian propaganda has
fabricated this hypocritical narrative
that supplying Ukraine with weapons
fuels the war
Ukraine indeed needs weapons
just as a firefighter needs water to
extinguish a fire
the fire that is destroying your home
and killing innocent people
the sooner and the more we get the
sooner the fire will be extinguished
arming a country that defends itself
from the aggression is absolutely
legitimate and is an act of defending
the U.N Charter
on the contrary
helping an aggressor is illegitimate and
defies the charter
any supply of weapons or military
equipment to Russia means complicity in
the trampling of the U.N Charter
if you give weapons to Russia you commit
a crime
in the short term Ukraine needs to
restore its sovereignty and territorial
Integrity within its internationally
recognized borders
and in the long run
Justice must be served
the Nuremberg International military
tribunal's verdict was crystal clear
war of aggression is not only a war
crime
it is the Supreme International crime
distinguishing itself from other war
crimes only in that it contains the
accumulated evil evil of the whole
this is why we call for the
establishment of the special tribunal
with specific jurisdiction over the
crime of aggression against Ukraine and
the ability to deal with personal
immunities of principal perpetrators of
this crime
the geography of Russian crimes against
International Peace and security goes
far beyond the borders of Ukraine and
reaches Africa Asia
and the Middle East
Russia not only incites conflicts but
also systemically obstructs U.N security
Council decisions needed to resolve them
today Russia argued that this council is
overly focused on Ukraine and ignores
problems of the rest of the world
let us all remember the truth
Russia is the problem of the world
I opened the UN Charter that I have here
in front of me and I do not see the
words member states can attack other
member states at their will end of quote
I don't see the words violating borders
is allowed
and furthermore and most importantly I
do not see the words the Russian
Federation in the U.N Charter on the
list of permanent Security Council
Members
in 1991
Russia observed the USSR seat of the
permanent security council member
and turned it into the Throne of
impunity
the future of Russia in the United
Nations should be determined in the
context of the illegitimate change of
plates from USSR to Russia in 1991 and
responsibility for crimes committed on
the territory of Ukraine
including war crimes crimes against
humanity and genocide
I say it again and again
peace means Justice
and all the peace-loving nations will
win peace on the battlefield
and at the Diplomatic tables
finally
on this tragic day when we mourn lives
and destinies broken by Russia
I kindly ask everyone
to observe a minute of Silence
in memory of the victims of the
aggression I thank you Mr President
foreign
of the Russian Federation has asked for
the floor to make a statement
Mr President we are getting up on our
feet to honor the memory of all victims
of what has happened in Ukraine starting
in 2014 all of those who perished all
lives are Priceless and that is why
we're rising to honor the memory of them
all
I think the representative
for their statement
what can you write
thank you
I I thank his Excellency Mr culeba for
his uh statement
I shall now make a statement in my
capacity as Minister for foreign and
European Affairs and trade of Malta
I begin by thanking Secretary General
Gutierrez for his briefing administer
kuleba for his statement excellencies
we have convened to mark one year since
the Russian Federation launched its
aggression against Ukraine
this brutal unprovoked and unjustified
war is a blatant violation of the United
Nations Charter and international law
it has brought immense suffering
destruction and misery on Ukraine and
its population
the war is also a stain on the very
principles that we here are bound to
uphold
it has also compounded the global food
and energy crisis
further adding to the already difficult
humanitarian situations being
experienced by vulnerable countries and
populations around the globe
at the outset I reiterate that every
state has the Sovereign right to
self-determination including the choice
of its own destiny in order to ensure
its Safety and Security
over the past 12 months ukrainians have
shown incredible courage and resilience
by defending not solely their right to
exist in the vase of a brutal military
aggression but also the values and
principles underpinning the
international rules-based order
over the past year
various U.N and international mechanisms
have provided evidence of indiscriminate
killings of civilians attacks on
civilian infrastructure torture
and other forms of cruel inhumane and
degrading treatment
sexual and gender-based violence
abductions enforceable deportation of
children
such actions constitute serious
violations of international human rights
law and international humanitarian law
and our grave breach of the Fourth
Geneva Convention
these children must be returned to their
families or legal Guardians without
delay
the tragic impact of these transfers and
deportations on ukrainians children
will be felt for generations to come
we must redouble our efforts to ensure
accountability for violations of the U.N
Charter and international law including
International humanitarian law and human
rights law
this must include Justice for victims of
atrocity crimes and sexual violence
perpetrators must be brought to Justice
and held to account without delay
we therefore welcome the important work
being carried out by the independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine
we also reaffirm our support for the
mechanisms that are working in this
fight against impunity
we stand with the prosecutor of the
international criminal court in his
investigations and continue to consider
ways to ensure accountability for the
crime of aggression
we also call on the Russian Federation
to respect the ruling of the
international court of justice ordering
an immediate suspension of military
operations
on this occasion I must also Express a
deep concern with regard to nuclear
safety in Ukraine
shelling in and around nuclear power
plants in Ukraine including zaporizia
Nuclear Power Plant
constitutes a grave environmental and
health threat and a serious risk to
International Peace and security
such actions can lead to a grave
humanitarian and the environmental
catastrophe with long-term repercussions
in the context of auditory rating Global
non-proliferation architecture
any declarations by Russia suggesting
that the possible use of nuclear weapons
is in any way Justified are unacceptable
such rhetoric only leads to uncertainty
further undermines trust between parties
and only serves as a means to escalate
the conflict and heightened tensions
this aggression also had serious
repercussions on the rules-based
international order that we have all
agreed to
as members of the International
Community our collective security
depends on these common principles
underpinned by the notion that might is
not right
no state or power has the right to
redraw borders in accordance to its
geopolitical interests
military affirms its full support
for Ukraine's Independence sovereignty
and territorial integrity
as committed multilateralists it is our
duty to defend and promote these
principles and to counter contempt for
them
in closing
as a member of the security Council
motor will continue to support all
efforts to address the consequences of
Russia's aggression
we also reiterate that the only step
towards a lasting peace would be for
Russia to immediately seize all
hostilities
and to unconditionally completely
withdraw all of its forces and military
equipment from the entire territory of
Ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
I resume my function as president of the
council
and I now give the floor to his
Excellency Mr Anthony blinken secretary
of state of the United States of America
Mr President
Mr Secretary General
fellow council members
one year and one week ago
on February 17 2022
I warned this Council that Russia was
planning to invade Ukraine
I said that Russia would manufacture a
pretext
and then use missiles tanks soldiers
cyber attacks to strike pre-identified
targets including Keith
with the aim of toppling Ukraine's
democratically elected government
Russia's representative
the same representative who will speak
today
called these and I quote groundless
accusations
seven days later
on February 24th 2022
Russia launched its full-scale invasion
due to Fierce resistance by Ukraine's
Defenders
President Putin failed in his primary
objective to conquer Ukraine and its
existence as an independent country and
absorb it into Russia
then he dusted off his Crimea Playbook
from 2014.
he called Snap referenda in four
occupied parts of Ukraine deported
ukrainians bust in Russians held sham
votes at gunpoint and then manipulated
the results to claim near unanimous
support for joining the Russian
Federation
when President Putin couldn't break the
Ukrainian military
he intensified efforts to break
Ukrainian spirit
over the last year
Russia has killed tens of thousands of
Ukrainian men women and children
uprooted more than 13 million people
from their homes
destroyed more than half of the
country's energy grid
bombed more than 700 hospitals 2600
schools
and abducted at least six thousand
Ukrainian children some as young as four
months old and relocated them to Russia
and yet
the spirit of the ukrainians remains
Unbroken
if anything
it's stronger than ever
when Ukraine launched a
counter-offensive that retook large
swaths of its territory
President Putin conscripted an
additional three hundred thousand men
throwing more and more of Russia's young
people into a meat grinder of his own
making
and he unleashed the Wagner group
mercenaries who have committed
atrocities from Africa to the Middle
East and now in Ukraine
of course
that's not the whole story of the last
year
there's also this story of Ukraine's
people
vastly outnumbered
they have fought bravely to defend their
Nation
their freedom
the right to determine their own future
and they've demonstrated inspiring unity
in helping one another endure moscow's
Relentless assault
teachers and community members give
classes in bunkers to children
city workers improvise patches to
restore heat and power and water to
residents
neighbors set up soup kitchens to feed
the hungry
there's also the story of how the
International Community Has Come
Together
the vast majority of member states have
voted multiple times to condemn Russia's
violations of the U.N Charter and reject
its illegal attempt to seize Ukrainian
territory
yesterday
141 countries voted in the general
assembly for a resolution that reaffirms
the core principles of sovereignty and
territorial integrity
denounces Russia's atrocities expresses
support for a just and comprehensive
peace in accordance with the United
Nations Charter
when President Putin tried to weaponize
hunger
exploiting the worst Global food crisis
since the creation of the U.N
the International Community responded
swiftly
since the United States chaired a food
security meeting last May
more than 100 countries have signed on
to a set of concrete commitments to
alleviate hunger
thanks in large part to the Secretary
General Gutierrez and turkia the Black
Sea Grant initiative loosened Russia's
Stranglehold on Ukraine Sports
and brought down the cost of grain for
the world
now as Moscow again tries to throttle
its output we have to ensure that that
initiative is extended and expanded
when President Putin tried to weaponize
energy
we redirected natural gas supplies from
across the world so the country's Russia
targeted could keep their people warm in
the winter
and Europe took extraordinary steps to
end its dependence on Russian energy
no country has endured greater hardship
from Russia's War than Ukraine but
almost every country has felt the pain
and yet Nations around the world
continue to stand with Ukraine
because we all recognize that if we
abandon Ukraine we abandon the U.N
Charter itself and the principles and
rules that make all countries safer and
more secure
no seizing Land by force
no racing another country's borders
no targeting civilians in war no Wars of
aggression
if we do not defend these basic
principles
we invite a world in which might makes
right
the strong dominate the weak
that's the world this body was created
to end
and members of this Council have a
unique responsibility to make sure that
we do not return to it
we can do that in three ways
first
we must push for a just and durable
peace
now I expect that many countries will
call for peace today
no one wants peace more than the
Ukrainian people
and the United States is long made clear
even before this war that we're prepared
to engage in any meaningful diplomatic
effort to stop Russia's aggression
against Ukraine
but history teaches us that it's the
nature of peace that matters
for peace to be just
it must uphold the principles at the
heart of the U.N Charter
sovereignty territorial Integrity
Independence
for peace to be durable it must ensure
that Russia can't simply rest rearm and
relaunch the war in a few months
or a few years
any piece that legitimizes Russia's
seizure of land by force will weaken the
charter and send a message to would-be
aggressors everywhere that they can
invade countries and get away with it
president zielinski has put forward a
10-point plan for a just and durable
peace
President Putin by contrast
has made clear that there's nothing to
talk about until Ukraine accepts and I
quote the new territorial realities
while doubling down on his brutal
tactics
members of this Council have a
fundamental responsibility to ensure
that any peace is just
endurable
council members should not be fooled by
calls for a temporary or unconditional
ceasefire
Russia will use any pause in fighting to
consolidate control over the territory
it's illegally seized and replenish its
forces for further attacks
that's what happened when Russia's first
assault on Ukraine froze in 2015.
look at what followed
and members of this Council should not
fall into the false equivalency
of calling on both sides to stop
fighting or calling on other nations to
stop supporting Ukraine in the name of
peace
no member of this Council should call
out for peace while supporting Russia's
war on Ukraine and on the U.N Charter
in this war
there is an aggressor
and there is a victim
Russia fights for Conquest
Ukraine fights for its freedom
if Russia stops fighting and leaves
Ukraine the war ends
if Ukraine stops fighting Ukraine ends
the fact remains
one man
Vladimir Putin started this war
one man can end it
second
even as we work to end Russia's war
against Ukraine members of this Council
must continue to address other
challenges to International Peace and
security
we hear the concerns of countries who
worry that standing with Ukraine and
holding Russia accountable is diverting
focus and resources from others in need
to those countries I would say simply
look at our actions
and when you hear Russia and its
Defenders accuse the countries who
support Ukraine of ignoring the rest of
the world I say look at moscow's actions
Compare the numbers
in addition to the 13.5 billion dollars
in food Aid that the United States
contributed to Fight Hunger over the
last year we also fund more than 40
percent of the world food program's
budget
Russia contributes less than one percent
of that budget
that's not an outlier
based on the latest U.N figures the
United States donates over nine times as
much as Russia the U.N peacekeeping we
donate 390 times as much as Russia to
UNICEF we give nearly a thousand times
as much as Russia to the U.N Refugee
agency
third
we must reaffirm our commitment to
upholding what the U.N Charter calls and
I quote the dignity and worth of the
human person
we must continue to compile evidence of
Russia's ongoing and widespread
atrocities
including
executions
torture rape and sexual violence the
deportation of thousands of Ukrainian
civilians to Russia
we must continue to document Russia's
war crimes and crimes against humanity
and share this evidence with
investigators and prosecutors so that
one day
the perpetrators can be held accountable
day after day of Russia's atrocities
it's easy
to become numb to the heart
to lose our ability to feel shock and
outrage
but we can never let the crimes thrush
as committing become our new normal
is not normal
earpin is not normal
bombing schools and hospitals and
apartment buildings to Rubble is not
normal
stealing Ukrainian children from their
families and giving them to people in
Russia is not normal
we must not let President Putin's counts
a difference to human life become our
own
we must force ourselves to remember
that behind every atrocity in this
wretched War
in conflicts around the world
is a human being
I recently visited an exhibit of artwork
made by Ukrainian children affected by
the war
one painting I saw was made by a 10 year
old girl named Veronica
last April
Russian forces shelled her home in
bulladar
killing her whole family
when First Responders dug her from the
rubble
a piece of shrapnel was lodged in her
skull
her left thumb had been ripped off
doctor saved her life
but the attack left her right hand
mostly paralyzed and she can't see out
of her left eye
in her painting
Veronica Drew herself in a bright pink
and orange dress
holding a bouquet of flowers
a building stands next to her
when asked who lived there
she said it was a place where all the
people she knew who had been killed in
the war
could be safe
we the peoples of the United Nations
determined to save succeeding
Generations from the scourge of War
that's how the U.N Charter begins
fellow members of this Council
now is the time to meet that promise
there are so many people in Ukraine who
want the same thing as that little girl
Veronica
a world where they can live in peace in
their own country
and keep the people they love safe
we have the power
we have the responsibility to create
that world today
and for generations to come we cannot
we will not let one country destroy it
thank you
I think his Excellency Mr blinken for
his statement
I now give the floor To Her Excellency
Minister for Europe and Foreign Affairs
of Albania
of the council
let me start by thanking Malta for
organizing this meeting a new Minister
for sharing it
we are grateful to the Secretary General
for his powerful words
and also for his continued genuine
efforts to end the war in Ukraine and
above all for his moral Clarity during
this unprecedented crisis
colleagues this is a tragic anniversary
there is nothing to celebrate rather
everything to regret
but still there is one crucial thing to
note and never forget
out of a disastrous war and its terrible
consequences we've seen a world
remarkably United in condemning a war of
choice in refusing territorial
annexation by force in upholding the
international law and in defending the
U.N Charter again yesterday
141 member states from all corners of
the world confirmed with a resounding
voice that they do not want a world
according to Russia but a world
according to the U.N Charter but they
want peace a just peace for Ukraine and
its people in line with President
zelenski peace plan
colleagues one year ago Russian troops
rushed across the borders of Ukraine and
Russian missiles filled its sky
unleashing the brutal war that continues
to this hour
with Russia
what Russia started on this very
Day last year has been cataclysmic for
Ukraine Earth shattering for Europe
history shaping for the world
thousands of civilians have lost their
lives millions of children have lost
their schools countless people have lost
their homes Millions more have been
displaced and the damage to the
infrastructure and economy of Ukraine is
simply unfathomable
Millions around the world especially the
poorest and most vulnerable have
suffered greatly because of the global
Ripple effects especially in the spike
of food crisis
throughout the year the world has
witnessed with dismay has verified and
documented despicable crimes executions
rape pillaging torture deportation of
children war crimes and crimes against
humanity committed by The Invader we
have witnessed thousands of convicts
being pressed into into service and used
as Canon folder in the ranks of the
Wagner group a murderous machine with a
notorious footprint in other parts of
the world
and the most appalling of all of it
is that an unjust illegal and unprovoked
War of aggression against an innocent
country and people is perpetrated by a
permanent member of the council who
Bears a special responsibility for
guaranteeing peace and security and for
upholding the U.N Charter in
international law
instead it has chosen to behave like a
rogue State going against the law
against the rules against the world
the truth is that despite everything
Ukraine is still here its people are
suffering but fighting resisting bravely
and defending their land their freedom
their future
and they are not alone their fight is
also the fight of everyone who aspires
for peace
and I have to Echo and I strongly agree
with Minister culeba that peace means
Justice
Mr President
Russian leaders like to talk about
history and their countries role in it
and Russia of course has much to be
proud of during its history but
countries and their leaders are judged
Above All by their ability to learn from
the past and their actions in the
present and at the present Russia has
nothing to be proud of with its wrong
actions with its disastrous policy and
its criminal War Russia has isolated
itself and it is only itself to blame
for it the sooner ordinary Russians will
understand this the sooner this madness
will stop
colleagues this war must end and it will
end but the end we envisage is the end
of aggression not the end of the rules
uh based world order it is the end of
the presence of Russian troops in
Ukraine not the end of life there it is
the end of unnecessary suffering not the
end of Hope there must be and will be a
future with a just and stable peace with
the free and secure Ukraine Sovereign
and with its territorial Integrity
restored and we look forward to the day
and I hope soon of the start of a
process of healing and reconstruction
but until that day comes Ukraine and its
people deserve all of our political
economic and Military Support all our
continued solidarity in their heroic
resistance to defend themselves to
defend the rights and the just slavo
crani thank you for your attention
I think Her Excellency Miss chachka for
her statement and I now give the floor
to his Excellency Mr Juan Carlos
Minister of Foreign Affairs and human
mobility of Ecuador
gracias thank you Mr President for
convening this debate as we mark one
year since the beginning of the military
aggression against Ukraine the first
bombs which began to fall while this
Council was meeting in this very same
chamber annihilated diplomatic efforts
on the part of the International
Community and the fervent appeal of the
Secretary General Antonio guterres who
was asking the Russian Federation to
give peace a chance
today I will focus on three key points
first of all the grave
humanitarian and Global consequences of
this war
second what this Council and the United
Nations have been able to do and third
what is now necessary for the
restoration of peace and security
Mr President the consequences of this
grave military aggression were
disastrous from the very first day
indeed 72 hours later the USG informed
this organ about the horrific
humanitarian situation on the ground
among the hundreds of thousands of
people who fled from this absurd Russian
aggression were around a thousand
Ecuadorian people many of those had to
be evacuated Byers as part of Emergency
Operations in a coordinated fashion
alongside other countries in South
America such as Colombia Peru and Mexico
many of these Ecuadorian people were for
us living testimony of the Grave
humanitarian consequences of the
invasion consequences which continue to
worsen day by day and minute after
minute even as we hold this debate this
is not a conflict which is focused on
Ukraine it was an attack on the world it
is an aggression on Latin America too
with 14 million people forced to leave
their homes eight million living as
refugees in Europe and almost 6 million
internally displaced persons the most
Gravely affected are women girls and
boys
the war now has around 18 million people
living in need of protection and
assistance the destruction of jobs and
the economic Devastation wrought are
worsening this fourth tragedy and are
placing
existing mechanisms for the protection
of human rights under stress summary
executions sexual and gender-based
violence torture and other inhumane and
degrading treatments are among the
ingredients used for cruelty in this war
what one year ago the council was warned
of just how brutal and protracted the
Urban War could be this warning was not
sufficient to Halt the use of explosives
in populated areas or the attacks
targeting critical infrastructure energy
infrastructure residential
infrastructure Health educational and
productive infrastructure or attacks
against the cultural heritage and
identity of Ukraine including museums
and religious sites this council is
inflicting pain and destruction on the
people of Ukraine it additionally
heightened the nuclear threat it
worsened food insecurity at a global
level and affected all economies in
particular those of developing nations
moreover it affected the working
dynamics of this Council and undermined
confidence in the United Nations system
this brings me to my second point
over these last 12 months the United
Nations system has mobilized the
security Council has met for at least 50
times to consider the situation in
Ukraine Ukraine's president was even
able to participate remotely this
Council thanks to the uniting for peace
mechanism with its resolution 2623
convened the 11th emergency special
session of the general assembly that
session adopted six resolutions focused
into Alia on territorial Integrity the
humanitarian question accountability and
the resolution which we had just adopted
yesterday with an overwhelming majority
on the principles of the United Nations
Charter underlying a comprehensive just
and Lasting peace for its part on the
16th of March 2022 the international
court of justice justice ordered the
Russian Federation to immediately
suspend its military operations and the
Secretary General has played a crucial
role in the evacuation of civilians the
release of prisoners and on other
humanitarian issues including on the
Black Sea grain initiative
the international atomic energy agency
is also deployed in nuclear power plants
in Ukraine to reduce existing risks Mr
President as has been outlined the
United Nations is mobilized but no one
no effort will suffice to ease the pain
of thousands of fathers or mothers that
continue to bury their children or the
tragedy of those thousands of girls and
boys that are now orphans how do we
justify to this generation of Ukraine's
people that one deer they woke up with
bombs missiles and gun power raiding
down to never again see their loved ones
because some died and others fled how
many more Horrors must Prevail for this
absurd war to end how many more meetings
of this Security Council do we need to
Halt the military aggression against
Ukraine this brings me to my third and
final point on what we still can and
must do
first of all the council must
unequivocally reject attempts to Annex
territories by force and must reject
violence as a tool of domination between
states this is not a vision of the West
as we hear time and time again it is a
sacred principle for developing
countries whose only weapon is
international law and whose only
ammunition is the provisions of the
charter secondly
we must see the immediate cessation of
the abuse of unbiased implementation of
article 27.3 of the charter According to
which the party to a dispute must
refrain from voting thirdly the members
of this Council must either collectively
or individually
readable our support for the efforts and
good officers of the Secretary General
as well as for the interagency work
underway fourth what better way to honor
the lives of the victims of this Council
than by guaranteeing that there are
independent investigation mechanisms and
accountability and reparation as tools
for redress but also as deterrence
and finally and most importantly
the Russian Federation must put an
immediate end to the unprovoked and
unjustifiable War withdrawing its
occupying troops to allow a realistic
ceasefire aimed at restoring peace and
Security in Ukraine peace and security
grounded in the respect for their
sovereignty territorial integrity and
political Independence
today for all of the children that have
died and for the injured and for those
that continue to live beneath the
Specter of the bombs we appeal for this
war to last not one day longer thank you
very much
I think his Excellency Mr huguin for his
statement and then I'll give the floor
to his Excellency Mr Ignacio Cassis
Federal counselor and head of the
federal department of Foreign Affairs of
Switzerland
thank you Mr President
ladies and gentlemen members of the
council
distinguished member states invited
guests I thank Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez for his commitment to peace
I would like to assure you
of Switzerland's support for the
council's action
during my first visit to Ukraine in
October 2021
I discussed uh
reforms and construction projects with
the political authorities we were
talking about a stable and prosperous
future for Ukraine
and the contrast with my second visit
last fall to KF under the bombs is
chilling
and distressing
the Russian aggression against a Ukraine
is an enormous shock for Switzerland as
a deposit depository and party to the
Geneva conventions my country is
committed to the principles of peace and
sovereignty as enshrined in the United
Nations Charter
for 12 months this Charter is being
violated and the Geneva conventions
which sets limits to the barbarity of
War have been flouted
but Switzerland believes in the power of
law
I therefore call for full respect of the
essential rules of international
humanitarian law the civilian population
the wounded prisoners and vital
infrastructure
must be protected by all parties to the
conflict
and by all combatants
it is more than necessary to recall
these commitments to which all of us
here have subscribed
we must do everything to ensure that
they are respected on the territory of
Ukraine where war is Raging
so what can we do specifically and
concretely we could for example meet in
the spirit of the Geneva conventions
meet to discuss together the means and
necessary to ensure that in the midst
of this heartbreaking conflict we do not
forget what defines us as human beings
namely the principle of humanity
Switzerland is ready at any time to
bring everyone around the table in order
to work for a better respect of
international humanitarian law and
ultimately for peace
next year
we will commemorate the 75th anniversary
of the Geneva conventions let us not
wait a year we must act now
Mr President distinguished colleagues
after your War we must gather our
strengths our ideas and resources to
restore Security in Europe and ensure
their return to a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine
Switzerland therefore welcomes the
resolution adopted Yesterday by the
general assembly it is a clear signal
from the vast majority of member states
in favor of solidarity dialogue and
peace
in order to make peace in Ukraine
possible I reiterate today our appeal to
Russia
we urge them to cease all hostilities
and withdraw all of its troops from
Ukrainian territory without delay
aggression threats and disinformation
are damaging to the foundation of the
international order
to prevent this
we need strong and effective
multilateralism
we need to restore
our mutual Trust
and to ensure that Justice is done so
that peace can be built on solid
foundations
as a permanent neutral State Switzerland
fully respects its obligations under the
law of neutrality it doesn't favor any
of the belligerents in military terms
but
neutrality does not mean indifference
we cannot be indifferent to violations
of fundamental rights along with 40
other states Switzerland has referred
the situation in Ukraine to the
international criminal court and now I
now call on all states to cooperate with
the court
faced with a report of war crimes sexual
violence and other serious violations of
international humanitarian law and human
rights we cannot stand idly by
Mr President
Switzerland continues to support Ukraine
at the same time Switzerland does not
forget the victims of all other
conflicts in the world the United
Nations Charter must serve as a compass
Beyond borders and convictions
Switzerland is on the side of
international law this is an essential
condition for lasting peace the goal to
which we have committed ourselves as
members of the security Council
thank you for your attention
I think his Excellency Mr Cassis for his
statement
and then I'll give the floor to his
Excellency
Mr yoshimaza Hayashi Minister for
foreign affairs of Japan
thank you Mr President I thank you for
organizing this important meeting
my appreciation also goes to the
Secretary General
today right here in the spirit chamber
right in the middle of the discussion on
how to prevent aggression against the
claim
a permanent member of the security
Council launched an aggression against
Ukraine in front of the wide open eyes
of the council members
it was an insult to the security Council
and to the entire United Nations
it demonstrated how little Russia cares
about the U.N
at that very moment I remember bibidri
Secretary General Taylor's called on the
lotions reader I quote
President Putin stop the military
operation
bring the truths back to Lucia unquote
his call still echoes in my ears
the core of the Secretary General
represent represents the collective will
of the member states
maybe except for a few
and it is reflected in the resolution of
the general assembly including the one
adopted just yesterday and in the icj
order from provisional measures
it is unfortunate that one year later
we still have to repeat the same call
Mr President
Japan condemns Russia's oblation against
Ukraine in the strongest possible chance
it is a clear violation of international
law including the U.N Charter by a
permanent member of the security Council
which is supposed to Bear the heaviest
responsibility for the maintenance of
International Peace and security
Russia must immediately stop its wall
overglation withdraw all of its troops
and military equipment from crane
and respect to claims Independence
solventry and territorial Integrity
within its internationally recognized
borders
no country is allowed to relight borders
by force or question
Japan also condemns Russia's attacks
against critical infrastructure
indiscriminate attacks on innocence
billions are a violation of
international humanitarian law and
constitute a war climb
Russia's irresponsible nuclear electric
and its seizure and mutualization of
this application Nuclear Power Plant
must be denounced as well
we commend and fully support the work of
the iaea to ensure nuclear Safety and
Security at the plant
we must hold Russia accountable in
accordance with international law
Mr President
we will stand firmly with the claim
Japan welcomes president zielinski's
since cifos to demonstrate fundamental
principles in its peace formula and to
promote a comprehensive just and Lasting
peace in accordance with the principles
and Shrine in the U.N Charter
before closing allow me to reiterate
that any attempts to change the status
quo or territory by force equation must
be rejected anywhere in the world
at the same time the security Council
should not leave behind many other
challenges that it has to deal with
Let Us return to the to the unshakable
principles that the member states have
built upon since 1945.
let us unite for the Lula blow let us
uphold the rule of law for peace I thank
you
I thank his Excellency Mr Hayashi for
his statement and I now give the floor
To Her Excellency miss Catherine Colona
Minister for Europe and Foreign Affairs
of France
Mr President I thank you for having
convened this meeting and I wish to
extend particular thanks to the
Secretary General and to Dimitri coliba
for their statements
on the 24th of February 2022 Russia
Unleashed a war of aggression against
Ukraine it had already occupied a part
of that country's territory for eight
years it Unleashed that war with no
other justification than its obsessive
desire to resurrect a past which had
however been condemned by history and
since then it has used the most extreme
violence to deny the identity of a
country and a people
today marks one year of Russia sowing
death and destruction one year
356 lot 65 long days that is one year
one year of Russia flagrantly violating
the fundamental principles of the
charter of the United Nations it does so
despite the fact that it is one of the
permanent members of the security
Council one year of inhumane suffering
for the Ukrainian people whose
resistance and courage command
admiration one year of war crimes and
crimes against humanity one year of
violence execution shelling of Civilian
targets of torture rape of abduction and
the deportation of children one year of
systematic violations of human rights
and of international humanitarian law
crimes that the international criminal
court is investigating and crimes for
which when the time comes it will
establish responsibilities those of the
executioners and those of their sponsors
one year and millions of lives stolen
destroyed or turned upside down what
today Mark's one year of Russia
flagrantly violating many resolutions of
this Council this is for example the
case of resolution 2231 on Iran here we
reiterate to the United Nations our call
for an investigation to be conducted
into the transfers of drones by Iran to
Russia and the deliveries to this
country by North Korea of missiles and
ammunition one year that Russia has
wielded nuclear rhetoric which is
irresponsible on the part of a nuclear
weapons States and this rhetoric
imperils the safety of Ukrainian power
plants Russia does not bulk at occupying
these power plants to support its
aggression here I wish to commend the
efforts of the iea and its director
General to guarantee the Safety and
Security of the zaparita plant and of
the other nuclear power plants in
Ukraine one year that many countries
have been forced to Grapple with growing
food insecurity and tensions on Energy
prices which are the direct consequence
of the Russian war
Mr President
we are one year in the factor on the
table there is an aggressor Russia which
didn't is denying its responsibilities
and there is an accuracy Ukraine which
defends itself but which also talks of
peace and here has made a proposal which
respects the principles of our common
Charter and the values of our
organization values which are the very
Foundation of our collective security it
is this path that yesterday the general
assembly called upon us once again to
follow by way of a vast majority of 141
States it did the same in recent months
in condemning the Russian aggression and
the illegal annexations
Ukraine is exercising its right to
self-defense
a right bestowed upon it by the United
Nations Charter this is why alongside
our partners we will continue to provide
Ukraine with the support it needs for as
long as is necessary because there can
be peace nowhere or stability nowhere if
aggressions are rewarded no peace and
security anywhere Mr President one year
later the Russian aggression must cease
the rules of international law must
finally be respected and Ukraine must
recover its sovereignty and territorial
Integrity the international court of
justice
made just that Appeal on the 16th of
March 2022. consequently we call upon
Russia to finally show itself worthy of
the responsibilities conferred upon it
as a permanent member of the security
Council and to put an immediate end to
its War regression against Ukraine I
thank you
I thank Excellency is Colona for her
statement and I now give the floor to
his Excellency Mr James cleverly
Secretary of State for foreign
Commonwealth and development of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland
Mr President thank you Mr Secretary
General thank you also
today we mark one year since President
Putin began his full-scale invasion of
Ukraine
three months ago I traveled to Kiev
Ukraine's foreign minister who is
sitting with us here today greeted me
uh and he had promised to host me for
lunch as representatives of countries
often do
but I arrived just after another Russian
missile attack on civilian
infrastructure had knocked out the water
and the electricity Supply to that City
but dimitro
Kiev were not going to let Putin's bombs
stop him from doing his job
and the restaurant that hosted us rigged
up a generator
and bought in liters of bottled water
and they provided the lunch
now we've all given and received
diplomatic Hospitality in our job but
that is the kind of diplomatic Hospital
hospitality
that shows something very important
it was a clear demonstration that whilst
ukrainians may have been hit and hit
hard
their spirit will not be broken that
restaurant wanted to show me that they
would not give up
but they would keep calm and carry on
dimitro kept his promise to me
and all of us in this chamber today need
to keep our promise to Ukraine and keep
our promise to the world to protect and
defend the U.N Charter
over the past year Putin has shown that
he is willing to wage a war of attrition
and the 20th Century's two world wars
have shown us what a horror that would
be
hundreds of thousands more dead and
wounded
Global shortages of food and fuel
skyrocketing prices
for these reasons and many more
Putin cannot must not win in Ukraine
because what's at stake on the
battlefields
is the international order itself
and that is at the heart
of the United Nations
the UN Charter
territorial integrity
international law
these things exist to protect countries
that do not themselves have big and
powerful armies and it is to protect
them from the aggression of those
countries that do
at the end of the second World War
the United Nations
saw a unique thing in human history
powerful Victorious Nations
chose to limit their own power
to protect the country's less powerful
than themselves
and that is the bottom line that is why
the U.N Charter needs to be protected
and it needs to be enforced
and it is why three quarters of the
entire membership of the United Nations
have repeatedly voted to condemn this
invasion in the general assembly
but
President Putin ignores the will of the
United Nations he doesn't care
about the U.N Charter
on the 24th of February last year he
told us that it was not Russia's plan to
occupy Ukrainian territory on the 8th of
December he called his illegal so-called
annexations a significant result for
Russia his land grabs in eastern and
southern Ukraine show us that his heart
is set on Imperial expansion
but
800 Russian soldiers a day
are dying
for his hopeless ambitions
they are paying for his ego with their
lives
as he sees that his aggression against
Ukraine is failing we should expect him
to try and strong arm us into backing
down with every dirty coercive
instrument at his disposal with cuts to
grain and energy shipments with threats
of escalation with poisonous
disinformation and with cyber attacks
and we must be prepared for this and we
must recognize that these things are a
sign of weakness rather than a sign of
strength
those of us in this chamber
have a special responsibility to the UN
Charter and we cannot allow Putin's
Invasion or his threats
to succeed
we must not deviate from our resolve
and the UK is proud of the support that
we have given Ukraine
but military assistance
and humanitarian Aid are not enough
because when this war is over
and it will be over with
Ukraine's successful defense of its
territory
we must never allow Ukraine again to be
left vulnerable to attack
we must make sure that Ukraine is safe
and secure
an economically viable
and that is why the UK is proud to
co-host the Ukraine recovery conference
in London in June of this year
together we must mobilize the combined
might of the public and private Finance
to ensure that Ukraine gets the
Reconstruction investment that it needs
but what Ukraine wants
what we all want
is for this war to end now
and to end with a victory for Ukraine
and adjust an enduring peace based upon
the UN Charter because only this can
bring an end to the food and fuel
shortages that the whole world is
suffering from
one year on
one year into this terrible terrible War
let us in this chamber send a clear
message
our support for Ukraine is not
and will never be time Limited
our defense of the UN Charter is not
we will keep the promises that we made
to the U.N Charter and to the Ukrainian
people and we will give the ukrainians
the help that they need for as long as
it takes
until Ukraine prevails
until its sovereignty and territorial
Integrity is restored
and until this Charter of this
organization is upheld thank you
I think his Excellency Mr cleverley for
his statement
I give the floor to his Excellency Mr
kwaku operatroom sarpong
Deputy Minister for foreign affairs and
Regional integration of Ghana
thank you Mr President
thank you Mr Secretary General
I thank Malta in his capacity as the
president of the security Council
for convening this debate on the
maintenance of peace and security of
Ukraine
I also thank the Secretary General
Antonio Gutierrez for his statement
about the leadership
and the past 12 months on the
humanitarian security and political
aspects of the war
in support of our shared ambition
ambition for an end to the war in
Ukraine as a return to the cherished
principles of peaceful settlement of
disputes
Mr President
I wish at the outset to reaffirm Ghana's
deep commitment to the sovereignty
political Independence and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine
we Retreat our solidarity with the
people of Ukraine as World ravages their
Farms towns and cities
we recall
us at the security Council convene an
emergency session on the night of the
24th of February
2022 amid widening concerns of an
eminent attack against Ukraine our worst
fears were born out before our very eyes
giving the firm denials by the Russian
Federation to any accessions that the
mountain presence of its troops along
its share borders with Ukraine was in
preparation for an invasion of Ukraine
Ghana at that time had urged for the
de-escalation of tensions and the
tampering of War ritual
regrettably that night as the council
met the Russian Federation without
justification began its actions to
violate the sovereignty and territorial
Integrity of his neighbor in Ukraine
as has been accepted so many times the
aggression by the Russian Federation
against Ukraine constitutes a serious
violation of international law and
stands today as one of the clearest
violation of the prohibition against the
use of force under article 2-4 of the
United Nations chapter
over the past year
as we have called upon the Russian
Federation to end this destructive War
we have listened carefully at each turn
to his attempt to rationalize the
ongoing actions in Ukraine
between the reality on the ground and
the changing narratives including
protection of ethnic Russians in parts
of Ukraine from russophobic attacks our
assessment remains that the ongoing
aggression against Ukraine is by all
standards unlawful unjustified and
unacceptable
in our view
conventional Frameworks and judicial
mechanisms such as the Human Rights
Council
and the international court of justice
should serve as the only acceptable
records in addressing any claims of
human rights violations
we therefore consider it untenable that
the permanent member of the security
Council entrusted with the distinct
responsibility
for the promotion and maintenance of
International Peace and Security will
choose the path of War
to the exclusion of diplomatic and
internationally acceptable means at its
disposal
by the Russian Federation on the 25th
February
of the security Council dropped
resolution intended to end the military
offensive
have regrettably prevented the council
from taking decisive action
the present circumstances underscores
the long-standing arguments for the
Urgent reforms of the council and the
prohibition of use of the veto
especially
in matters affecting International Peace
and security
more so where a permanent member of the
council is the one in Bridge of the
charter and international law
the war on Ukraine
As We Know
has preceded by efforts to address
certain concerns with the post Cold War
European security architecture
we believe that any revisions of the
existing structures that guarantee
collective security office members must
emerge from broad Dino
involving all relevant actors in the
region
we are concerned that the Fallout from
the continuing war in recruiting our
attempts to create
or reinforce opposing alliances a
situation who took us to Two World Wars
we believe that this is the time for
Kula has
and the rededication to mutually
beneficial cooperation
and multilateralism not competition for
hegemonic Advantage
those who wish to dig in their heels for
selfish advantage in the geopolitics of
the 21st century will lead us now the
pit of even greater disaster
Mr President
the world has Unleashed a devastating
humanitarian toll
and claim thousands of life
sustained Mr bombardments merely
targeted civilian population areas have
resulted in more than 21 000 casualties
including 8006 deaths and 13
287 Indian
it is saddening to know that 478
innocent children have been killed the
954 Indian
millions of people have been displaced
with eight million living as refugees in
neighboring countries
our own National compatriots most of
whom were college students had their
education disrupted and translated when
they were forced to flee from Ukraine
we are informed that about 50 percent of
Ukraine energy infrastructure has been
destroyed or damaged
this situation has left many household
without heating or water and at the
mercies of the Halloween winter
conditions we regret that hostilities
have carried on without regard for the
principles of proportionality and
distinction and therefore we Retreat our
condemnation for the targeted attacks
against civilians and civilian
infrastructure
Warren parties have obligations under
International humanitarian law which
they must comply with
it is important
to see the aggression against Ukraine
in any light except as an attack on the
accepted standards of our International
order
and allowing it to stand
impels the independence and the quality
of States under the charter especially
of the less powerful states
we must therefore sustain the political
world for accountability
first to ensure Justice for the people
of Ukraine and not the least for the
preservation of the present
International order
the coordination of ongoing
investigative processes as well as the
strengthening of our International
justice system
including the
universalization of the Rome statue
and the international criminal court
remained crucial to ensuring that the
perpetrators of atrocities you regret
like elsewhere do not go unpunished
we recognize the courageous efforts of
the environmentarian workers who have
worked under very difficult
circumstances to provide life-saving and
life-sustaining assistance to some 16
million people and urge International
support to help fund the Ukrainian
humanitarian response plan
with the 3.9 billion that is required to
Aid nearly 40 percent of the population
with varying humanitarian requirements
the president
the rest of the world has not been
spared after shocks of the war which
continue to reverberate with crippling
and systemic impacts on global food
energy and finance systems developing
countries already have developing
countries have been hard hit by the
impact of covid-19 pandemic
debt and inflation have lateral coping
capacity for the Western economic
conditions
we take note of the useful policy
recommendations put forward by the
global crisis report Response Group on
food energy and finance to address the
Vicious Cycle of the crisis including
the restructuring of the global debt
architecture We Believe
priority should be given to implementing
those recommendations especially to
support Africa's economic transformation
and his capacity to address the growing
debt crisis and the Interline
consequences of the war
given the centrality of Russia
Federation and Ukraine in the global
grain and fertilizer markets we support
the federal renewal of the Black Sea
grain initiative to ease Global Market
volatility that hold long economic
effects necessary attention must also be
given to realize the effective
implementation of the mou between the
United Nations and the Russian
Federation on the export of
agro-products and fertilizers Mr
President
we are acutely concerned by the growing
appeal of military logic and the
hardening of the conflict to a war of
attrition
the war is moving
in the direction that leaves much
concern as the events of the past 12
months have demonstrated that no one is
immune from the consequences of the
world
in Ukraine we have a responsibility to
read double our efforts to avert the
catastrophe of a more brutal work that
we have in witness to so far
the resolution on a just piece in
Ukraine adopted Yesterday by the general
assembly under the 11th emergency
special session in affirmation of the
values and purposes of the charter of
the United Nations should ignite a
renewed commitment to take the actions
needed to realize our Collective
aspirations for lasting peace between
the two countries we strongly believe
that the channels of diplomacy and
dialogue offer the best chances of a
just comprehensive and a lasting peace
and urge the members of this Council to
strengthen their efforts in support of
credible negotiations between the two
parties we have later option than to
invest in peace in concluding Mr
President we retrace our call for the
Russian Federation to return to the
status school until
through the immediate and unconditional
withdrawal
of his truths from all areas within the
international recognized borders of
Ukraine
I thank you for your kind attention
I think his Excellency Mr operatroom
sarpong for his statement and I now give
the floor to her excellencybe
permanent representative and assistant
Minister of Foreign Affairs and
international cooperation for political
Affairs of the United Arab Emirates
thank you Mr President I also thank the
Secretary General for his briefing and I
welcome the participation of Ukraine's
foreign minister today in this meeting
we cannot begin except with an
expression of deep sorrow for the lives
lost and shattered in the war in Ukraine
we more in the at least 8 000 civilians
killed and we share in the grief of
their loved ones
we are pulled as we mark one year of
this cruel war that we do so in the
knowledge that it enters its second year
over the past two days from the podium
of the general assembly we heard a
virtually uninterrupted appeal for peace
a global diverse and representative
majority issued an unambiguous message
enough
this majority is United by neither
allegiance to one side nor hostility to
the other
they come together not to preserve
geopolitical gain or reverse loss
they are not motivated by Petty
grievance or grand ambition
they have no interest or ability to wade
into great power conflict
in the historical processes and events
that Forge today's Europe they were for
the most part observers too often
unwillingly impacted
yet
the incontestable fact is that an
overwhelming majority of member states
are rising to the defense of the UN
Charter
it is the charter that upholds
sovereignty Independence and territorial
integrity
it is the charter that rejects Wars of
aggression conquests and annexation
it is the charter that organizes our
open and Cooperative International order
the question is simple and it is settled
those truths however self-evident are
nonetheless challenged by the war still
raging on Ukraine military setbacks have
been met with military escalation while
the front lines are little changed the
costs however have only grown
in Ukrainian lives and livelihoods in
the damage to cities and towns in the
destruction of Civilian infrastructure
the war's reach has extended far beyond
Ukraine
disrupting food and energy markets
worsening the global debt crisis and
weakening International Norms rules and
laws
exactly one year ago today the global
call for diplomacy and peace went
unheeded as the war broke out
now we risk its escalation as more
battalions mobilize for new offensives
yesterday member states renewed their
urgent and sincere call for an end to
this war leaders across the world are
responding with mediation efforts and
peace plans
now is the time to invest in inclusive
and imaginative diplomacy by truly
leveraging This Global majority for
peace
we must reinforce the secretary
General's offered role as a mediator
with consistent robust and determined
backing
the post-war Vision must also
incentivize Russia and Ukraine to the
negotiating table not to the battlefield
the war will not end if either side is
more threatened by the alternative
steered by the charter and history we
can dedicate ourselves towards a peace
that is neither vindictive nor callous
we are under no illusions that this
effort will be easy too much blood has
been spilled too much damage has been
done but all of us should dread with
equal certainty what looms in the wake
of its failure
Mr President Richard Holbrook once
described an effort to end a different
war in Europe as something like a
combination of Chess and mountain
climbing reaching the summit at which
this war ends will require a series of
small moves
renewing the Black Sea grain initiative
realizing the mou on Russian fertilizer
and food products preserving the
non-proliferation regime enhancing
humanitarian assistance continuing
prisoner exchanges and refraining from
turning multilateral institutions into a
Battlefront
to achieve all of that we must Aspire
for coordination in our approaches not
conformity
and we must encourage indeed nurture all
efforts motivated by a genuine desire to
peacefully resolve this war to do that
we must value not vilify open lines of
communication
that is the path the UAE has chosen it
is the path we have pursued in defense
of the UN Charter for a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine
preserving its sovereignty Independence
and territorial Integrity with its in
within its internationally recognized
borders thank you Mr President
I think her
excellencyba for her statement
and I now give the floor to the
representative of Gabon
thank you Mr President I wish to thank
the Secretary General of the United
Nations for having
reminded us of the scope of the
principles of the United Nations and for
having provided us with a horrific stock
take of the war in Ukraine at 12 months
after it was first unleashed the war in
Ukraine is almost exactly one year old
we've seen an entire year of a bloody
war which undermines and tests the whole
of the international systems its shock
waves are having an impact on the
majority of the world Nations this has
been an entire year in which deaths can
be counted in their thousands this has
been a year of unbridled destruction of
Civilian infrastructure a year of
distress or fear of Exodus
a year where the number of refugees and
displaced persons continues to grow in
line with shelling and under the rattle
of gunfire every day that this horrific
War continues increases the risk of the
conflict spilling over
spilling out of all control and sees the
risk of a globalization of hostilities
increase every year that this every day
rather that this day continues increases
the power of the Specter of risk that is
the risk of a nuclear war which would be
without a doubt the path of no return
damage and Chaos this war is
unsustainable and must immediately cease
from the very onset of hostilities my
country has expressed its opposition to
the war and has condemned the violation
of the territorial Integrity of Ukraine
we have reaffirmed in unequivocal terms
the principles of the United Nations
Charter as the very Foundation of our
peaceful coexistence above all my
country has time and time again called
for an immediate ceasefire and for good
faith negotiations between the parties
to silence the guns in Ukraine Mr
President over the last 12 months
the members of this Council have spoken
out in the most forceful terms around
this table over the last 12 months each
Rostrum of the United Nations every body
of the United Nations has been a theater
for the exchange of insults and
antagonistic rhetoric which are of no
Aid or assistance for those falling in
the trenches or for those crushed under
the rubble and on the battlefields those
that have fallen in cities and Villages
it is time to stem the blood flow and
the rivers of human suffering which
callers to action and pique our
conscience it is time to mobilize it is
time for us to mobilize to put an end to
the war in Ukraine as members of the
security Council we oh
a response to all those killed and
injured in the war we owe a response to
the countless victims that are asking
themselves when the war will end we owe
a response to the countless refugees
that are asking when they can return
home
we must without delay bring our action
in line with the spirit of the United
Nations Charter which promises to spare
this generation from the scourge of War
my country reiterates its appeal to
parties to engage in good faith
negotiations in order to put an end to
this war The Hope sparked by the Black
Sea Green initiative must be revived not
only in order to guarantee the renewal
of that agreement but also to build a
bridge for candid dialogue which will
ultimately lead to a cessation of
hostilities we call upon parties to
exercise restraint and responsibility
they must be accountable before history
history which will always be bigger than
the illusion of immediate gains and the
glory of imposing hegemonies which have
no promise or tomorrow I want to again
express my
country's opposition to this war to the
war in Ukraine and opposition to all
wars in the world namely those that are
so numerous so chronic and cyclical as
those in Africa rejecting the logic of
war is not a form of neutrality
cowardice or an opportunistic stance
it's not the expression of powerlessness
or indifference rather it is a way of
learning the indelible lessons of
History the lessons that have taught us
time and time again that those that
cause maintain or trigger Wars are
rarely the winners of them
taking a step back from the logic of War
whose options are often so narrow
is to
remain in step with the ideals that form
the very foundations of the United
Nations nobility
because War runs counter to the values
which founded this United Nations
organization and this Security Council
every day
of War calls into question our vocation
our mandate and our credibility to
conclude I wish to stay once again
that we appeal for peace in Ukraine
because we are for peace
and because of that we will always
support efforts for dialogue and we will
support every initiative designed to
open the channels of diplomacy in order
to silence the guns in Ukraine thank you
I thank the representative of Gabon for
the statement I give the floor to the
representative of the Russian Federation
Mr President
today is the last day of a week which
was anything but simple and it will be
remembered by one and all for the
information hullabaloo which was created
by Ukraine its Western sponsors
uh related to the one-year Mark of the
Russian special military operation in
Ukraine and it would seem that this is
what was
um what the promise boils down to the
promise made by Mr culeba in January to
have a peace Summit in New York so as to
analyze what was said by our former
Western Partners during this week
um we could without exaggeration convene
a whole political science conference and
probably possibly that this will happen
in future will people will want to cast
a retrospective eye on this and for such
a political science conference we could
propose the following title yet another
missed opportunity to peacefully resolve
the Ukrainian crisis and this would be
right because any expression using the
word peace which are being
disingenuously used including today by
high representatives of Ukraine and
Western countries what is meant is
actually something completely different
what is meant is the capitulation of
Russia and inflicting a strategic defeat
on Russia ideally followed by the
disintegration of the country and
redrawing the territories it and it
includes these two goals over Western
interference and Ukrainian Affairs were
clearly displayed by the way almost
exactly nine years ago on the day of the
maidan anti-constitutional coup on the
21st of February 2014
and people didn't hide them from the
very beginning and these are exactly the
goals which resulted in the fact that on
our borders we have a hostile
nationalistic russophobic regime which
decided that they would resolve the
Ukrainian issue with zeal
our British colleague yesterday when
um she spoke on the general spend
assembly and she criticized the uh
Belarus submitted amendments to the
draft or resolution she stated that the
Amendments equate the aggressor and the
victim are you not at all concerned by
the fact that your victim has is up to
its elbows in Blood and Nazi tattoos and
the nine-year-old period of elimination
of russian-speaking citizens in donbass
do you think it's normal why do you
think it's normal for Ukraine to send
guns and tanks against unarmed civilians
in the East and bomb them only because
those people do not want to give up on
their own identity
because that is exactly what the key of
regime did in the summer of 2014 and it
was then then the internal Ukrainian
armed conflict erupted do you think that
we were supposed to resign ourselves to
this situation please allow me to remind
you that it's aggression against
Yugoslavia was justified by NATO by The
Campaign Of Terror and the need for the
kosovirus to live in security and enjoy
Universal Human Rights and Freedoms on
an equal basis this is a quote a quote
from a statement made by NATO on the
23rd of April 1999.
so then you and your other colleagues
then deny the Russian speaking
ukrainians the universal rights and
freedoms if you present the key of
authorities Who attack them as a victim
you also are silent about the campaign
of Terror Unleashed against them for us
it is obvious that Ukraine is not a
victim because if Ukraine did not wage
war against the people in donetskin
lugansk as you condoned it but rather
heeded their aspirations then our there
would there would have been no need for
our special military operation and the
Crimea probably would have remained
within Ukraine because the people of the
Crimea only decided to choose
reunification with Russia only after
their direct threats from the key of
authorities
I would like to take opportunity over
the fact that we have Miss Colona and
miss berberg here at the meeting
and I would like to raise yet one more
very inconvenient for a western
colleagues topic namely the Minsk
agreements we have all heard recently
the confessions made by Francois
Hollande by Angela Merkel and by Boris
Johnson they said that neither France
nor Germany nor the United Kingdom ever
viewed the agreement seriously had no
intention to urge the Ukrainian
authorities to implement them and only
use the agreement so to buy the time and
give key of time to prepare for a war
with Russia
now even if you disregard the dimension
side of the issue and we Have No
Illusion about the moral qualities of
our Western colleagues by now the what
we have here is that the leaders of
these states openly basically stated
that the newly violated Security Council
resolution 2202 which enshrined the
business agreements but this does not
stop the Ministers of Foreign Affairs of
these very States
from lecturing other member states here
in the council today
furthermore
a tried cliche we heard during this week
and it appeared a lot earlier it
consists of the fact that if Russia is
to end the war the war will end and if
the Ukraine will end stop fighting there
will be no Ukraine
it sounds pretty but it's absolutely
false where when and from whom did you
hear that the goal of our military
operation is to destroy Ukraine 2D
ukrainize Ukraine we have never stated
such a goal
we have always wanted to have right next
to us as was the case before to have a
friendly neighbor who doesn't threat us
does not discriminate against anyone and
is not trying to resurrect Nazism
therefore this slogan of yours in actual
fact should be as follows if Russia
stops hostilities the Ukraine will
continue discrimination against the
russian-speaking people those who do not
want to live with violence the its
rights and freedom will will continue to
be violated in the glorification of Nazi
criminals will continue if Ukraine and
hostilities it will get the chance to be
reborn as a normal peace-loving State
and will save many thousands of lives
and that is why we're updated on many an
occasion that we are ready to
negotiate about how the goals of our
special military operation could be
implemented using peaceful means and but
of course any mechanism which are by
other kind of scenarios we are not
prepared to consider colleagues we have
stated many times this week that ND
hostilities in Ukraine is not something
that the collective was is interested in
and only Collective West alone they
um as we know for a fact prevented the
key of regime for making peace in April
last year and our Western colleagues
currently are happy with everything the
Russians and ukraines are killing each
other the Western defense companies are
getting fabulous profits and they have a
platform for testing new weaponry and
NATO is getting rid of its old weapons
and is rear Army but what and Washington
is also weakening its European
competitors who are displaying
heretofore unseen Civility and impotence
and this is something that we talked
about at lengths in this chamber
yesterday and most importantly the West
is rubbing his hands and hoping that it
will weaken Russia will threaten China
and will keep its Monopoly position in
the world Remain the only so-called
blossoming Garden as was stated by Mr
Burrell in in in on this jungle Planet
then the top golden billion will
continue enriching itself at the expense
of others pitching countries against
each other using their natural resources
and exploiting its people and that is
what is meant by the rules-based order
which Russia dared infringed upon
because we don't want to
um accept a russophobic wasps nests at
our borders we want to make sure that
the developing developing countries have
no Illusions about what this conflict is
really about and of course resolving
this conflict is inseparable from the
issues having to do with just and
um indivisible system of European and
Atlantic security currently it only
works for the United States and its NATO
allies they arrogated to themselves the
right to interfere in any international
issues and Internal Affairs of other
countries Ukraine is a very good example
their bases are deployed and on our
borders in violation of key
understandings ending the period of Cold
War Western leaders lied to us then and
want to continue deceiving us now
for them it is the right of nature to
expand uncontrollably is ABS is absolute
and they keep telling us tall tales
about how much money they spend all for
developing purposes as was just done by
state Secretary blinken let me just
recall here that after the Cold War
alone the United States conducted 251
military operations abroad and
inflicting Untold damage on those
countries even if you pay 100 times more
than you do now you will not be able to
make up for that damage the collective
West need to understand and accept the
fact that there are other players on the
planet with their own entrance and you
have to coexist with them or you can
even cooperate them in mutual interests
but this has to be done on an equal and
respectful basis a uni polar world is in
the past and it's our mutual interest to
make sure that we transition to a
multipolar word with as few upheavals as
possible and we would like to hope that
the Ukrainian crisis will be the last
hot phase of such a transition this is
how a genuine discussion of Peace should
look like possibly within the UN and the
sooner we start talking about it like
this the better we try to start such
such a dialogue before the special build
your operation at the end of 2021 but
overall our proposals to have such a
dialogue was spurned by the West the
prize was paid by the Ukrainian people
the key of regime sacrifice the
Ukrainian people for the purpose of
Western geopolitical interests we
welcome genuine efforts to have peace
such as for example the Chinese proposal
though the choices here is up to our
former Western Partners first and
foremost Washington obviously after
everything we've discovered about you
this year after a limitless and
um discussing russophobia and the
attempts to cancel Russia after
supplying the zelinski regime with
weapons which were used to kill
women children and the elderly Don boss
after your Ukrainian adventure and
trying to create on
um um to create difficulties for us on
our borders our relations will never be
the same we do not believe you and
restoring our trust will be very
difficult if at all possible because
what's important here are Deeds not
words but attempting to do this it's in
your interest at this point you're just
worsening the situation by continuing to
pump the key of regime with weapons and
helping them in the battlefield
and you leave us with no option rather
other than to eliminate threats to
Russia from the territory of Ukraine
militarily please bear this in mind when
you start making up new anti-russian
initiatives at the UN and pass them off
as evidence of support for Ukraine in
the world I thank you
I thank the representative of the
Russian Federation for the statement I
give the floor now to the representative
of Mozambique
Mr President
Mozambique wishes to thank the
presidency of Malta
for convening this important meeting
we express our profound gratitude to the
Secretary General
for his enlightening statement
Mr President
Ayah has elapsed since the outbreak of
the conflict in Ukraine
its tragic consequences and spillover
effects and ramifications
continue to reverberate at local
Regional and Global levels
and no end is inside
as with every conflict
civilians
especially women and children
are bearing the brunt of the violence
and those alive
will remain
traumatized
forever
on the other hand
the conflict has negatively impacted the
World Trade
and Supply chains
it has brought economic damage
with global threat disruptions
affecting Transportation causes
and virtually all Global value chains
the socio-economic impact on development
countries especially Africa
has been grave
the IMF
has found that while the African
continent
was slowly rising from the coveted
pandemic
the conflict in Ukraine is now
threatening this recovery
menu of our countries
are vulnerable
due to the higher energy and food prices
reduce to tourists and potentially
difficult
accessing
International Capital markets
from an African perspective
we are all too familiar with the
devastating effects of conflicts
we know that wars only result
in the suffering of people
and it is our
Collective Duty
the duty of the International Community
as a whole
to work towards resolving conflict
through peaceful and negotiated
Solutions
we need
to uphold
the fundamental principle
of collective security
enshrined in the chart of the United
Nations
According to which the security of one
is the security of all
Mr President
in the past
the global Community has shown that it
is possible to overcome hate and mutual
suspicion
and find the path to the negotiating
table
it is therefore imperative that the
International Community
support all the Diplomatic efforts
to end the conflict in Ukraine
this requires the support of all Nations
particularly those who hold a seat on
the security Council
we need to assist the parties
involved to engage in negotiations and
reach a negotiated
solution
this means
building on the few bright Sports
of this year-long conflict
such as the Black Sea initiative
the regular exchange of prisoners
and the secretary General's Global
crisis response group on food energy and
finance
and more importantly
Mozambique thinks that we need to
strongly support
the good officer of the Secretary
General
of the United Nations
and
tap on his Reservoir
of moral Authority in search for the
settlement of the conflict
Mr President
Mozambique has a long-standing
commitment
to promoting peace and Security in our
region and Beyond
as a country that has experienced
numerous conflicts in the past we
understand
the importance of supporting diplomatic
efforts and respecting humanitarian law
to bring about peace
the one year anniversary of this
conflict
must serve as a reminder for the
International Community to work together
towards
finding a negotiated solution to the
conflict
Guided by the purposes and principles of
the United Nations chapter I thank you
Mr President
I think the representative of Mozambique
for this statement and I give the floor
to representative of Brazil
thank you Mr President and I thank
Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez for
his statement
one year after the start of the conflict
we see an armed still mate on the ground
triumphalus rhetoric on both sides and
Prospects of new military offensives
we should put aside Illusions about a
military solution to this crisis
we need to discuss the return of the
parties to the negotiating table
president Lula has made Brazil's
position clear faithful to our
diplomatic tradition
we condemn the Russian invasion and the
territorial violation of the sovereign
state Ukraine
but a year later we understand that time
has come
to also give voice to those who want to
speak of ways to build peace
violence which affects the most
vulnerable should stop with no
preconditions International humanitarian
law and its principles are not optional
they are mandatory at all times and
under all circumstances
respecting and ensuring respect for
international humanitarian law is
essential to the protection of civilians
Mr President Brazil does not come with
the intention of presenting a ready-made
solution
we need to explore paths that seek to
create conditions for the end of the
conflict
we are convinced that countries like
Brazil which are not directly involved
in the conflict have a constructive role
to play in fostering dialogue
we acted in the sense during discussions
on the most recent resolution of the
general assembly adopted yesterday
member states called on the parties for
the cessation of hostilities an
expression that appears for the first
time at the suggestion of Brazil
the resolution also reaffirmed the
Resolute commitment of the International
Community to uphold the core principles
of the U.N Charter and international law
while underscoring the need to reach
peace
we also encouraged careful consideration
of the causes of conflict so that Mutual
resentments and suspicions do not
manifest in future violence
we should never lose sight of the human
drama
nor ignore the global economic impact of
the war in particular with regard to
Rising input costs for Agricultural and
food production
Mr President
Brazil will continue to persevere on
this path
we are convinced there is enough
willingness among member states
for avoiding in the future new
anniversaries on the duration of the war
such as the sad mark of one year
completed today I thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of Brazil for
their statement I give the floor to the
representative of China
Mr President
I thank Secretary General guterres for
his briefing
it has been one year since the full
outbreak of the Ukraine crisis its
development is causing great concern to
all of us the International Community
while deeply concerned about the
prospect of the expansion prolonging of
the conflict should think cool-headedly
about how to stop the fighting as soon
as possible and how to realize long-term
peace and stability in Ukraine and
Europe
China issued earlier today a position
document on the political settlement of
the Ukraine crisis we have always taken
an objective and impartial stance based
on the merits of the issue and are ready
to continue to play a responsible and
constructive role in easing the
situation resolving the crisis here I'd
like to highlight the following points
first
when handling and solving international
disputes universally recognized
international law including the purposes
and principles of the U.N Charter must
be about the sovereignty Independence
and territory Integrity of all countries
must be effectively guaranteed observing
universally recognized international law
and the basic Norms govern international
relations Bears on the stability of the
International System and its National
fairness and Justice they should be
equally and uniformly applied in every
place and on every issue without
exception some country while stressing
sovereignty and territory Integrity on
the Ukraine issue is blatantly
interfering other countries Internal
Affairs and undermining their
sovereignty and territory Integrity this
reviews its double standard at full
display the International Community is
clear diet about this second
to facilitate a political solution to
the Ukraine issue there is a need to
pursue common security
security is not an exclusive right
enjoyed only by some countries the
security of a country should not be
pursued as expense of others
strengthening or even expanding military
blocks were only under my original
security
and will never bring about peace
Russia Ukraine and European countries
are neighbors that cannot physically
move away
to realize lasting peace and stability
in Europe the Cold War mentality and
block confrontation must be abandoned
and the legitimate legitimate security
concerns of all countries must be taken
seriously and addressed properly so as
to build a balanced defective and
sustainable Regional security
architecture
third conflicts have no winners
long-term diplomatic negotiations is the
only right way to solve the Ukraine
crisis
the International Community should
promote peace and talks with the highest
sense of urgency and work to create
enabling factors and platforms for the
resumption of negotiation
bringing parties to the conflict back to
the negotiating table is not going to be
easy but it is the first step towards a
political solution
just now Secretary General guterres also
appealed that we give peace a chance we
call on Russia and Ukraine to resume
negotiations without any preconditions
Ukraine is not a arena for fights
between major countries no one should
seek to benefit from the conflict at the
cost of the Ukrainian people
fourth it is imperative to never cross
the red line of nuclear security under
any circumstances nuclear weapons must
never be used a nuclear war must never
be fought faced with the risk that the
Ukraine crisis could lead to an
escalation of the conflict major
countries bear special and important
responsibility to maintain communication
and coordination and to do everything
they can to prevent a nuclear crisis the
International Community should jointly
oppose armed attacks against nuclear
power plants or other peaceful nuclear
facilities
ensure strict compliance with the
conventional nuclear safety among others
and support the iea in playing a
constructive role in promoting the
Safety and Security of peaceful nuclear
facilities fifth
the humanitarian crisis is worsening and
should be proactively and properly
addressed the international humanitarian
law is a code of conduct that must be
strictly observed in Conflict situations
relevant parties should avoid attacking
civilians or civilian facilities
protected the vulnerable including women
children ensure humanitarian access and
respect the basic rights of prisoners of
war the International Community should
increase its in humanitarian assistance
help restore civilian infrastructure
ensure basic livelihood of refugees and
the displaced persons with a view to
preventing a humanitarian crisis on a
larger scale at the same time
humanitarian operations should in
Earnest follow the principles of
neutrality and impartiality and avoid
politicization SEC each country is
responsible for the important task of
promoting people's livelihood and
development efforts to be made to manage
the spillovers of the crisis the current
crisis has far richer impacts but but
the developing countries are not parties
to this conflict I should not pay an
excessively high price for it some
relevant parties have been resorting to
unilateral sanctions and maximum
pressure which cannot solve any issue
and can only undermine the stability of
the global industrial and supply chain
and exacerbates the global food energy
and financial crisis
we hope that the relevant parties take
responsible actions and stop abusing
unilateral sanctions and long-arm
jurisdiction the Black Sea grain
initiative and they are more used signed
by the U.N and Russia on exported food
products and fertilizers have great
significance for ensuring Global Food
security and should be implemented fully
and effectively in a balanced manner
Mr President
the rotary piece will not be smooth but
no matter how complicated the situation
is we must never give up our hopes for
peace and efforts for peace on the
Ukraine issue China has always stood and
will continue to stand on the side of
peace and dialogue
We Stand ready to work with all parties
to promote a political solution to the
Ukraine crisis and strive for the early
arrival of Peace thank you Mr President
I think the representative of China for
the statements
and I now give the floor to his
Excellency Mr Joseph Burrell High
representative of the European Union for
foreign affairs and security policy
thank you
thank you Mr President Secretary General
today exactly one year ago Russian tanks
roll into Ukraine is starting a major
invasion of a peaceful neighbor
and for one year
we have all seen ukrainians fighting to
defend their country
they deserve the solidarity of everyone
around the world every country and every
person
I would just make two essential points
first
while Russia wore Choice matter to all
of us
and second how to get peace
we need to be clear I said a war of
choice because this war
is the war of President Putin
choosing
and for one year
we have seen the Horrors
30 million people homeless 20 million in
need of humanitarian assistance and tens
of thousands of Ukrainian Force
to leave their country and seek Refuge
across Europe
families torn apart in a catalog of
crimes the forced deportation of tens of
thousands of Ukrainian children stands
out for his depravity
Abduction of innocent Ukrainian children
the challenging of their personal status
including nationality
to be adopted by Russian families is a
clear violation of Human Rights and
international law
and violates also the Geneva Convention
these children these Ukrainian children
need to be returned to Ukraine
immediately
so crimes against humanity
I've been to butcher and seen for myself
the civilians killed
with some having their hands tied behind
their back
before they were executed
and who can forget mariopol
I would again like to pay tribute to the
United Nations for their efforts in
securing the safe passage of civilians
trap
inside the Athos bastal stable plan
Russian forces have been selling
Ukrainian cities and civilian
infrastructure for months
air raid syrians
have become a disturbingly regular
future of Ukrainian lives
as I witnessed myself and many of you
when I was in cave 10 days ago
we in our pay yes one year on the
world's tall is devastating for the
Ukrainian people
however the effects of the war are also
global
spikes
in food insecurity and energy insecurity
are leading to price bikes whose effects
are catastrophic for the most vulnerable
people
Rising costs of foodstuffs and essential
Goods
have added an additional burden to the
already difficult daily lives of many
countries around the world it is for
that reason that this war affects us all
the European Union and its member states
have for a year contributed to
lightening this burden
this burden that is the consequences of
the war
in Africa for example
more than 1.5 billion euros have been
disbursed for food security initiatives
in the country's most affected in the
Sahel Lake Chad and in the Horn of
Africa
I didn't know
this war matters yes this war matters a
lot both for the principles at stake
and for the shock waves it's creating
and it needs to stop and it needs to
stop now
and this brings me to the second point
maybe the most important one
how do we get to peace because everybody
is asking for peace
but how
how do we get to peace
let's hear here at the United Nations
and around the world a growing clamor
for peace
that was the clear message that the
general assembly sent yesterday
while the security Council has been
blocked
the general assembly stated
with an overwhelming majority of 141
versus seven
that the world condemns aggression
that Russia must withdraw its troops
that the world wants and needs peace
but not just any peace
no
we want a Justice
based on international law at United
Nations Charter
and it is urgent for the Kremlin to hit
this message
and to act on it
look into the future
we need to build on this resolution and
make it happen
president zelenski has presented a 10
point peace plan and we support it
because we European Union we will remain
ready to work with all genuine partners
and ideas that support Ukraine's effort
to shakua a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace
as the SEC as the United Nations General
Assembly voted based on the United
Nations Charter and international law
and meanwhile
we will continue to support Ukraine to
defend itself and protect its people
because the surge of peace
and our support to Ukraine go hand in
hand both things together not either or
both
search for peace and support to Ukraine
and with that they want to make a final
point
our principal support for Ukraine does
not come at the expense of our
engagement elsewhere in the world
on the contrary
to repair Union remains fully mobilized
to promote sustainable peace elsewhere
because we know that there are many more
Wars many more tragedies many more
problems around the world
that needs our support and our concern
is not instead of
is on top of
we continue doing the same thing that we
have been doing until now
and we have a strong track record on
engagement around the world financially
politically with more than 5 000 women
and men deployed in 21 crisis management
operations
just this week we launched two more
one in Armenia and another in Niger
yes there are many other
many other problems many other War many
other sufferances around the world
we take care of them we work for the
peace in Ukraine
and be that reliable partner for peace
around the world wherever the peace is
in danger and people sufferances
thank you
I think his Excellency Mr Burrell for
his statement and I now give the floor
to his Excellency Mr rastis love Casa
Minister for foreign and European
Affairs of Slovakia
is it Mr President
one year ago the security Council had a
meeting In This Very Room
around this very table
and the main purpose of the meeting was
to discuss the unprecedented military
buildup of the Russian Force posing a
threat to International Peace and
security
The Last Hope to persuade Russia to
descalate the situation engage
constructively in negotiations was
shattered with the words of the
ambassador of Ukraine at the time
warning members of the security Council
that he was already too late to speak
about these escalation as the Russian
president he declare a war
and we all know this happened despite
numerous assurances of Russia claiming
they have no intention to invade its
neighbor
this was the night uh
when the whole International Community
was informed of Russia decision to begin
an unprovoked in unjustified military
aggression against Ukraine
in violation of all fundamental values
and principles of the U.N Charter and
international law
yes
that's Russian Federation holding the
permanent seat in this chamber is
primarily responsible for maintaining
peace and security
needless to say
that that moment the faith in a
multilateralism was shaken from its
foundations
despite the pain and suffering which
have been caused since the senseless War
started the Russian Federation has been
ignoring calls of the internal
International Community to end this
agony
and I do not really understand
in which parallel universe
depriving millions of innocent people of
electricity heat water and plunging the
country Into Darkness can be justified
under the pretext of so-called special
military operation
it is rather cynical how systematic in
thorough Russia has been in spreading
propaganda and distorting the facts
it seems that Russia has been promoting
some kind of alternative reality a
behavior which we condemn once again
we reiterate our call for an immediate
cessation of Russian military activities
in Ukraine
in unconditional withdrawal of all
Russian troops from the whole territory
of Ukraine
this also concerns temporarily occupied
Crimea as well as other territories of
Ukraine including those where the
Russian Federation together with local
puppet authorities orchestrated the
so-called referendum in blatant Bridge
or of international rules
we're extremely concerned about the
number of Civilian casualties enumerated
since the beginning of the invasion to
Ukraine
according to ohcrh it's uh well over 8
000 killed and over 13 000 injured but
needless to say we all know that the
fact that the real numbers are much
bigger than that
Slovakia has stood by Ukraine since the
very beginning of Ukraine defense
against Russia aggression and we will
continue our steadfast support
um of Ukraine including its independence
sovereignty territorial Integrity until
this Shameless War is Over
however it's also one fact which is
undeniable
the war will be over one day
and those responsible for all crimes
committed will be held responsible in
brought to Justice thank you Mr
President
I think his Excellency Mr cashier for
his statement and I'll give the floor to
his Excellency Mr Bogdan our rescue
Minister for foreign affairs of Romania
Mr President I commend The Maltese
presidency of the security Council for
organizing this open debate
for a year now Romania a direct neighbor
to Ukraine has been at the Forefront of
helping Ukraine and countering the
multifaceted consequences of the
atrocious illegal and unprovoked War
waged by the Russian Federation
the permanent member of the security
Council against Ukraine a sovereign
independent country
the impact of this irrational War has
reached far and wide violations of
international humanitarian law and the
attacks on critical civilian
infrastructure made millions of
ukrainians flee
grain and energy chains have been
disrupted leading to Sharp increase of
energy prices
and the threat of famine all over the
globe and especially to the most
vulnerable in the south
fear of a nuclear catastrophe don't ask
again hybrid tactics test or try to
intimidate us putting pressure on
Ukraine and its neighbors like the
Republic of Moldova others in the Black
Sea region or The Wider European
continent and the euro-atlantic security
area as a whole
this world represents a direct attack on
the Integrity of the rules-based
International System our security
prosperity and core values
but in front of this threat nothing is
clearer than this we will stand United
and strong for as long as it takes
Ukraine will win and Russia will bear
the responsibility for what it has done
our call is also clear
Russia must abide by the rules of
international law
that must unconditionally seize the use
of force and withdraw completely and
immediately from the territory of
Ukraine within its International
recognized borders
we are here today in the security
Council chamber the guarantor of
International Peace and security
to stand by the side of the U.N Charter
and international law
and reiterate that there is only one way
to end this aggression
I welcome the resolution adopted
yesterday in the general assembly by a
very large majority of states
which put the principles of the U.N
Charter above all including National
original interests
it is in our power to mitigate the
effects of this war on the future from
Diana of this world Romania acted in
full solidarity with the brave Ukrainian
people we made considerable investments
in food energy and transportation
infrastructure along with welcoming over
3.6 million Ukrainian refugees that have
transited our territory
so far we have facilitated the delivery
of over 13 million tons of Ukrainian
grain contributing to Global Food
security efforts Romania hopes for a
positive outcome in the long run and the
continuation of the Black Sea grain
initiative
Romania has also been a strong supporter
of the efforts to seek accountability
for all serious crimes committed in
Ukraine including the crime of
aggression we joined the core group of
states that works alongside Ukraine to
identify the most appropriate legal
basis to establish a tribunal to this
purpose
the ongoing war in Ukraine has a Major
Impact in the region we have extended a
helping hand to our neighbor the
Republic of Moldova the country most
affected by the war except Ukraine
itself
and I must bring to your attention that
we are concerned with Russia's latest
plan is to destabilize the country which
we condemned
in this respect it is absolutely
unacceptable to see threatening rhetoric
like the one including in the statement
of the Russian foreign Ministry of today
by which it announced that the Russian
army would I quote adequately respond to
so-called provocations or attacks
against the Russian compatriots and the
military personnel and Depot from the
transmission region of the Republic of
Moldova
such provocative Behavior based on
nothing
based on ungrounded allegations is
completely unacceptable
and we fully support the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of the Republic of
Moldova within its International
recognized borders
as we approach the one-year Milestone
since the beginning of the war all of us
including Romania witnessed the Russian
propaganda intensifying
spreading fake narratives in an attempt
to undermine the unity of our societies
and our efforts to support Ukraine we
must combat this malign influences as we
must continue to stand United to defend
our values
the Romanian people must be mindful
about the russian-inspired stories they
read and hear
but they shouldn't question our support
for Ukraine supporting Ukraine means
supporting Romania
Mr President said before this is the
test of Our Generation
we have to work together at all the
different layers of this conflict and
bring peace back to its deserving place
our message is straightforward peace in
full respect of the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine
peace in full respect of the event
Charter and of its fundamental
principles of international law and one
political and moral principle is clear
negotiations can start only when Ukraine
is ready and the way Victory looks like
must be defined by Ukraine Romania
support for Ukrainian remains solid for
as long as it takes thank you Mr
President
I think his Excellency Mr rescue for his
statement
and I now give the floor to his
Excellency Mr Speaker
Minister for foreign affairs of Poland
Mr President
excellencies
let me begin with expressing my
gratitude to Malta for convening this
important meeting and to the Secretary
General
for his valuable insights
excellencies
I believe
that we should focus today on three main
things first of all the accurate
diagnosis of a situation
when
research for an adequate
reaction and finally the steps that need
to be implemented
so let us start with contrasting the
truth against with disinformation and
misleading propaganda
and the truth is that exactly a year ago
Russia decided to start its illegal
aggression against Ukraine period
since then Russia's War has been putting
International institutions
to attest
it is testing our commitment to the
principles that protect us all
the humanitarian cost of this war are
horrifying
the aggression has caused the biggest
crisis in Europe since the Second World
War
Russia's Campaign Of Terror and sits
deliberate targeting of civilians and
civilian infrastructure are utterly
unacceptable
the kremlin's actions
are driven by the will to destroy the
Ukrainian Nation its Heritage and its
future
that is why I'm convinced that Russia's
barbaric aggression against Ukraine is
not a bilateral or Regional issue
it is a concern of all states
and we all have a duty to bring this
atrocities
to an end
secondly
the prohibition of aggression of
genocide and of crimes against humanity
are you Scoggins norms
this means
that no derogation from them is
permitted
Poland advocates for the full
accountability
for all the violations
and compensation
for the inflicted damage
saying so
what should be the guiding principle
for this approach
nobody has doubts whatsoever
that when we look at the domestic laws
of our countries
they stand on the premise that Justice
means the protection of a vulnerable
against the more powerful
the assertion is
that in a well-ordered society the
vulnerable need
to feel as secure as the powerful
and The Powerful
when they trespass the law needs to be
brought
fully accountable so that others are not
encouraged
to commit similar crimes in the future
if the International Community
is to draw from this horrific War and
the right conclusions
for future Generations
Poland believes
that we are required to search for
analogical Solutions in the
international law system
therefore
I call to introduce the same rule of
protecting the vulnerable against power
against powerful billions
in our international relations both in
the legal dimension and political
practice
let us build a well-ordered
International Community
in order to achieve that
International
institutions with all the resources must
stand on the side of the hunt
and execute accountability and
compensation from the aggressors
no matter how strong and powerful they
are
I cannot Envision the world without
adhering to this rule
can you
further
with respect to this Golden Rule
Poland's support to Ukraine is and will
remain unwavering
millions of ukrainians found safe refuge
in our country
in 2022 Poland spent over 9 billion US
dollars
that is 1.5 percent of our GDP
on humanitarian assistance to Ukrainian
refugees
according to the recent oecd estimate
we provide support and host over a
dozens of un agent agencies and
international organizations
helping
Ukraine from our territory
we will remain steadfast in our support
for as long as it takes
because we are motivated by the will to
protect the ukrainians and every other
nation in need
our actions
are about safeguarding Collective peace
and security
if we do not act in solidarity
now
interact from defending the fundamental
values of international law tomorrow it
can be too late
Mr President
excellencies
Poland stands firmly before behind the
values and principles of the U.N Charter
we refuse to go back
to power politics
and spheres of influence
very International Community Has the
strength
and will to stand by Ukraine and to
defend the U.N Charter so that the power
of argument not the argument of power
prevails thank you
I think his Excellency Mr Ralph for his
statement and I now give the floor to
his Excellency Mr Peter cesarto Minister
of Foreign Affairs and trade of Hungary
Mr President the Aryan thank you so much
for uh
organizing uh this session of the
security Council today
at the first anniversary
I'm representing a country Hungary which
is a direct neighbor
to Ukraine therefore the impacts of the
war are severe and immediate on us
and we are faced with the tragic
consequences
basically on a daily basis
as we are witnessing the suffering of
the people caused by this war
we have received a bit more than a
million refugees from Ukraine so far
unfortunately mostly torn apart families
I have to tell you it's heartbreaking to
see
the mother is arriving with the children
sometimes with the grandparents
mostly with one backpack to Hungary
we do want to
help them
we are doing our best to help them
we give equal access to the refugees
from Ukraine when it comes to our
education and Healthcare System
1 000 and 300 schools and kindergartens
in Hungary
have already been enrolling
Refugee kids and students from Ukraine
and we give incentive
to the companies in Hungary in order to
employ
refugees
all this together with many other
measures
are adding up for the largest
humanitarian operation carried out in
the history of Hungary
and I have to tell you that we are going
to continue
this large humanitarian action as soon
as long as it is needed
and from the neighborhood we see it very
clearly that this war
brings a lot of suffering
this war does not have winners
this war does only have losers
and the longer this war lasts
the more losers there will be
more damage will be caused and more
people will be killed
let me tell you that I'm representing a
Nation
which has a number of casualties in this
war as well
given the fact that there is a Hungarian
community living in the western part of
Ukraine members of which are Ukrainian
citizens obviously
so many of them are conscripted into the
Ukrainian Army
they are fighting on the front lines and
many of them have died already
and let me emphasize that we do not want
more people to die in this war
in this regard I'd like to underline the
position of Hungary that uh
we would consider as the number one duty
of the International Community
under such circumstances to save lives
of the people
and prevent more casualties
and the question is raised here how it
is possible obviously and the answer is
that you can save lives with peace
with deliveries of weapons with further
packages of sanctions I don't see
how we save lives of the people but with
peace we definitely could
and I know very well that for this
position of ours we are usually under
very heavy criticism
not only heavy criticism but on many
occasions totally insane accusations are
being put on Hungary and his government
but those who criticize us and educate
us judge us they have not lost any lives
in this war
unlike we hungarians
so that's why Mr President the Aryan
your colleagues we call for immediate
ceasefire and peace talks to be launched
as an outcome of which hopefully a
sustainable peace could be reached
and it is obvious that peace cannot be
made in case there are no channels of
communication open
if channels of communication are being
cut stuck closed
it means from our perspective that even
the Hope For Peace is being given up
and once again as a representative of a
neighboring country
witnessing the suffering on a daily
basis I humbly ask you
to concentrate on how to stop this war
how to avoid more people to die and how
to make peace
and the Aryan together with you I'm
representing and many of others a
generation which thanks God
did not have to experience
how life was during the World War
World War global war
and we do hope that uh
neither us
nor our children or our hopeful future
grandchildren we do have to experience
such a life
and so far
this war came with global impacts that's
not a question
the question is whether we can avoid
this war becoming a global war
a World War
whether we can avoid measures decisions
and even sometimes statements
which bring the risk of escalation and
prolongation of this war
I think all of us should refrain from
such kind of measures decisions and
statements
which prolong
and escalate this war
a third world war
would be a real tragedy
a third world war would bring us to
where hopefully none of us would like to
go
in this regard I think it's key that
there is no direct confrontation being
established between NATO and the Russian
Federation
in NATO we have a clear decision that
NATO is not party to the conflict and we
do hope that this decision of ours will
be respected by all
the area under your colleagues Hungarian
people are not responsible for this war
but Hungary and the Hungarian people
have already paid a high price that's
why
we all know that we are in the 25th hour
we are in the 25th hour so let's try to
concentrate on how to stop this war how
to put an end to this war how to
establish an immediate ceasefire and how
to launch pay stocks which hopefully
which hopefully will bring us to a
sustainable and fair piece thank you
I thank his Excellency Mr ziato for his
statement and I now give the floor to
Excellency the San Elena baboc Federal
Minister for foreign affairs of Germany
colleagues
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine is causing nothing but
destruction suffering and death
yesterday the general assembly sent a
powerful message against this ruthless
War
an overwhelming majority of
141 States
stood United for peace in Ukraine
a piece that is just comprehensive and
Lasting
and the general assembly presented a
peace plan
a peace plan that is based on the
principles of our un Charter
today the eyes of the world are on the
security Council
the body that bears primary
responsibility for the maintenance of
peace and Security in this world
every further effort to move towards
peace from a member of this council is
in my point of view valuable
but peace must mean peace
peace must not mean that we ignore who
the aggressor is and who the victim
because subjugation is not peace
not naming the aggressor would mean
accepting a world in which the mighty
rule
it would mean accepting a world in which
bombing schools kidnapping children and
shooting people off their bicycle is
part of foreign policy
not standing by the side of the victim
would mean a world in which none of us
would be able to sleep peacefully
because we would all have to fear and
attack our our stronger neighbor
to prevent such a world the united
nation was founded
that's why we cannot stand idly by
the charter obliges us us the nations of
the world to act
now that some of you claim that by
sanctioning the aggressor
by standing by the side of Ukraine by
supporting Ukraine by its right to
self-defense
we are adding fuel to the fire
I would like to ask you
where would you Crane That voluntarily
gave up its nuclear weapons because it
believed in peace
would be today if we had not supported
its right to defend itself supported
their people
elderly mothers fathers children
together with so many International
partners
can we imagine what this would mean
to have more butchers
mariopos more bachmuds matrocities
against civilians
more children wrong pictures with a
house where their beloved ones once
lived
imagine more crimes more crimes against
humanity and we would have stand Idol by
I don't want to imagine such a world I
don't want to be responsible for such a
world
I think most of us don't want to be
responsible for such a world
therefore I would like to underline with
secretary blinken said
if Ukraine stops defending itself
ukrainians if we would stop
standing the side of Ukraine
Ukraine wooden
the Russian Representatives asked just
a couple of minutes ago here in this
Council
why would we think that Ukraine would
end
well
because one year ago
your president just told us
that he would like to demilitize Ukraine
and we saw for
365 nights and days
what that meant
that your tanks didn't bring water
that your planes didn't drop baby
nutrition
but your tanks and planes only brought
night and day destruction and death of
thousands of fathers and mothers and
children
and yes it brought also death and
destruction around the world not
directly
by tanks and bombs but by the food
crisis and yes you everybody on Earth
can deceive yourself
but you cannot deceive the world
all those of us who sincerely and
honestly believe in the peace that means
peace
a piece based on the charter of our
United Nation must show their true
colors now
and stand by the peace plan by the
general assembly
President Putin is speculating that at
some point our clear stance against this
war will weaken
he's speculating that by staying the
cause
this war this Warfare regression will be
rewarded
for a war that is also causing great
suffering to his own people
some 200 000 Russians have already been
killed or wounded hundreds of thousands
of Russians have left their country
because they don't want to be part of
this war
Russian children going to schools in
Germany and I'm very happy about this
more than one thousand International
companies have pulled out of Russia
taking with them a crucial part of
Russia's prosperity and intelligence
this war is not the world's War
this war is not the war of the Russian
people
this war is Putin's War
the Russian president is risking the
future of his own country
of his own soldiers his own children
that's why it's just peace a peace plan
presented Yesterday by the 141 States at
the general assembly is also in the
interest of the people of Russia
when I look around this table
I'm under No Illusion
we will not convince the Russian
representative today he's not even
listening
but what we can do
is that this Council will not turn a
blind eye to butcher
Mario
to the people and the children of
Ukraine
what we can do is stand up for a world
where peace means peace
thank you
I thank Her Excellency Mrs burbok for
her statements and I'll give the floor
to his Excellency Mr Edgars rinkovitz
Minister for foreign affairs of Latvia
Mr President I'm speaking on behalf of
Denmark Estonia Finland Iceland
Lithuania Norway Sweden and my own
country Latvia
I sang the Secretary General for his
briefing and the presidency of Malta for
the opportunity to address the security
Council
a year has passed since Russia started
its brutal and Justified and unprovoked
full-scale War of aggression against
Ukraine aided by Belarus
it is a clear violation of international
law and the United Nations Charter
we admired The Bravery and Persistence
of ukrainians in the fight for their
freedom and Independence
we pay respect to all the Ukrainian
people who have died defending their
Homeland
Russia's illegal annexation of Crimea
and sevastopol and the full-scale
invasion of Ukraine has trampled
International norms and Rose based order
Russia a permanent member of the United
Nations security Council
is seeking to change the borders of a
neighboring sovereign country by
military force
this constitutes a serious threat to
International Peace and security
we will never accept Russia's illegal
annexations of Crimea Donetsk orchansk
her some androperation
we call on the Russian Federation to
abide by the icj order on provisional
measures of March 16 2022 to immediately
suspend its military operations that
commenced on 21st February 2022 in
Ukraine
Russia cynically disregards its
obligations as a permanent member and
hampers the security council's ability
to implement its mandate
Russia started this war
Russia can and must end it immediately
by withdrawing its troops from the
internationally recognized territory of
Ukraine
to make it happen we must provide all
necessary means to Ukraine
under the U.N Charter Ukraine has
inherent right of self-defense
the Nordic Baltic states are determined
to enhance Ukraine's military
capabilities and to provide all
necessary support
Mr President
unable to defeat Ukraine in its
Battlefield
Russia terrorizes Ukraine's Syrian
population
mass killings rapes and torture in
Butcher and resume
and the legal deportation of children
are only some of the most horrifying
atrocity Crimes of the Russian Armed
Forces
we condemning the strongest terms
deliberate attacks by Russia against
civilians
critical infrastructure and civilian
objects in Ukraine
to alleviate the suffering and
facilitator Construction
we provide economic political
humanitarian Financial
and legal assistance Ukraine and its
people
Mr President
Russia must and will be held accountable
for its crimes we support the work of
the international criminal court to
investigate atrocity crimes
in addition
the crime of aggression must be
addressed to bring to Justice the
Russian political and Military
leadership who masterminded and
Unleashed this war of aggression against
Ukraine
we believe that the U.N should play a
meaningful role in securing broad
International support for the
establishment of a tribunal or the
prosecution of the crime of aggression
Mr President
a Russia uses disinformation and
propaganda to mobilize domestic and
international support for its aggression
against Ukraine
it is extremely worrying that Russia
uses food and energy as instruments in
its Warfare
it causes suffering for the most
honorable Nations and people globally
Russia is cynically covering it by false
narratives and disinformation including
by dishonestly blaming sanctions it is
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine thus has aggravated and already
existing food security crisis and
augmented the rise in Energy prices
we support the bloxy brain initiative
and there is Russia to extend it and
stop delaying the work of inspection
teams
Mr President yesterday the general
assembly once again we confirmed the
international support for Ukraine's
sovereignty and territory integrity
we urge the U.N security Council to
uphold the U.N Charter which forms the
basis for just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
we welcome president zolenski's 10-point
peace formula we strongly support his
vision for peace that rests in
international law and the principles of
the United Nations Charter we will stand
by Ukraine for as long as necessary
thank you
I think his Excellency Mr rinkovicius
for his statement and then I'll give the
floor to his Excellency Mr Ruslan
volvochian Secretary of State of the
Republic of Moldova
Mr President
distinguished members
of the security council's excellences
the Republic of Moldova strongly
condemns Russia's illegal and unfounded
aggression against Ukraine we also
categorically reject the attempted
annexation of Ukrainian territories
as they commemorate one year of this
brutal War we mourned the enormous human
losses significant destruction of
Civilian infrastructure and the
displacement of countless ukrainians who
have been forced to flee their homes
to escape the horrors of War
Moldova is one of the countries which
sheltered hundreds of thousands of
Ukrainian people we will continue our
support to Ukraine for as long as it
takes
Ukraine defends its land and its freedom
and by that it defends our freedom and
our democracy too
we appreciate Ukraine's incredible
resistance we stand in solidarity with
our neighbors and our friends we stand
with Ukraine
distinguish audience moldovan Ukraine's
most fragile Neighbors has been greatly
impacted by Russia's unprovoked
aggressions
as while Ukraine is resisting a military
Invasion Moldova is on the front line of
a hybrid War which includes interrelated
gas blackmail cyber attacks propaganda
and disinformation
on several occasions our airspace has
been violated by Russia's missiles and
missiles debris landed on our territory
which is absolutely unacceptable
let me also stress that the Breakaway
transmission region of the Republic of
Moldova is getting regularly in the
spotlight including the in the recent
days
our country is firmly committed to
maintaining stability and peace in the
region in this complicated context and
to promote political settlement of the
conflict based on their sovereignty and
territory Integrity of the Republic of
Moldova within its International
recognized borders
we reiterate our position for complete
withdrawal of Russian military forces
and munition storage illegally present
in the region
all these challenges are real but so is
our Reserve to stay strong
the Republic of Moldova expressed its
deep gratitude to all partners who have
supported us in this time of crisis
despite all those risks Moldova ramades
committed to its path toward European
Union integration which represents the
best way to ensure peace stability and
prosperity for the country Mr President
over the past year
Ukraine has faced an unprecedented
attack against its sovereignty and
territory Integrity throughout this time
the International Community has stood
firmly with Ukraine in condemning the
aggression and supporting Ukraine's
efforts to Define its people and
territory
we have seen remarkable displays of
solidarity from the provision of
humanitarian assistance to the
Diplomatic efforts to bring about a
peaceful resolution to the conflict
the large support extended Yesterday by
the U.N General Assembly to the
resolution outlining the principles of
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine is another remarkable sign of
strong support in that regards Moldova
supports Ukraine in achieving a just
peace and accountability
we joined the calls for immediate
cessation of hostilities and complete
and unconditional withdrawal of the
Russian military troops and ammunitions
from the territory of Ukraine
enclosing the Republic of Moldova
reference its unwavering support to
Ukraine's Independence sovereignty and
territory Integrity within its
International recognition borders thank
you
I thank his Excellency Mr bobosham for
his statement and then I'll give the
floor to his Excellency Mr wobke
hochstra Deputy Prime Minister and
Minister for foreign affairs of the
Netherlands
thank you Mr President Mr President I'm
here today on behalf of the group of
friends of accountability
following the aggression against Ukraine
a group of 49 member states and the
European Union that share one strong
conviction
that the power of Justice should always
prevail
over the power of force
today it has been exactly one year since
Russia's full-scale invasion of Ukraine
and the people of Ukraine have shown
extraordinary courage and resilience in
their continued fight for freedom and
Independence
and we've seen horrendous images and
reports of the indiscriminate killing of
civilians
man
women and children
we've seen unlawful attacks on civilian
infrastructure houses schools and
hospitals
and we have seen horrendous reports of
sexual and gender-based violence and
abductions of children
presidents such actions are unacceptable
they violate international law
and wherever they occur they must be met
with the same strong response
this cannot stand
accountability and justice for Ukraine
for ukrainians
and for the International Community as a
whole
is of the utmost importance to ensure a
sustainable peace
yesterday the general assembly resumed
its emergency special session on Ukraine
and once again
the general assembly took a strong
stance in defense of the U.N Charter
by adopting a resolution on the
Charter's principles underlying a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
and in his resolution the general
assembly emphasized the need to ensure
accountability for the most serious
crimes under international law committed
on the territory of Ukraine
Mr President our quest for justice
are fired against impunity
are fired against violations of
international law
should not must not and cannot be
pursued without taking a firm Collective
stance against the aggressor
we command the efforts and initiatives
already taken to ensure accountability
this includes the deployment of forensic
missions to Ukraine
the opening of an investigation by the
ICC prosecutor
the creation of an international center
for the prosecution of the crime of
aggression and a register for damages
to be located in The Hague
we welcome the establishment of the
independent U.N Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine
and the establishment of the oece Moscow
mechanism
we commence the ongoing work of the
human rights monitoring mission
which has documented violations since
2014.
of particular concern are the reports of
conflict-related sexual violence
including rape as a tactic of War
and these crimes constitute serious
violations of international humanitarian
law
conflict-related sexual violence must be
countered through effective
accountability measures
measures that will contribute to
deterrence and prevention of these
horrendous crimes
Mr President Russia's aggression against
Ukraine violates the U.N Charter which
underpins peaceful coexistence and
Global Security
and we call on the Russian Federation
to abide by the order on provisional
measures by the icj of 6th of March 16th
of 2022.
the court stated that Russia shell
immediately ends the military operations
that had commenced on February 24 2022
in the territory of Ukraine
this is the first step
to put an end to the all too long list
of crimes which require accountability
which require Justice
the first step
to put an end to human suffering in
Ukraine and ease the human suffering
caused by Russia's War
in Ukraine
but clearly also globally
Mr President the violation of the U.N
Charter we are witnessing today
is an attack
on the International Community as a
whole
we should not just seek accountability
for what has already been taken place
we must strive we must strive to prevent
anyone
and I mean anyone from committing such a
violation ever again
Ukraine or elsewhere
thank you very much Mr President
I think his Excellency Mr hoxtra for his
statement and I now give the floor to
his Excellency Mr Antonio tayani Deputy
Prime Minister and Minister of Foreign
Affairs and international cooperation of
Italy
Mr President
on this day exactly one year ago a
permanent member of this Council una
literally violated the basic principles
and Norms on which the peaceful
coexistence among states and this very
organization are founded
far from being a greater sense of Duty
and responsibility as a permanent member
with this inaccitable Behavior Russia as
profoundly shaken and questioning the
roads of the international order
on this anniversary Ukraine's this
stands and together with the wide
majority of the International Community
Italy stands alongside Ukraine in full
solidarity with his people
but when I listen to somebody who talks
about Europe which is a slave of the
United States I need to say that we are
slaves of freedom of democracy of
international law so we need to
completely reject this idea of a Europe
being a slave to anybody we are the
homeland of a freedom and democracy
throughout the world it is unacceptable
what I heard this morning here in this
chamber Russia's illegal and provocative
Justified Act of aggression against
Ukraine not only
is a gross violation of the United
Nations and the threat to International
security and disability but is also
causing Global systematic disruption
with
multiple harmful consequences that
majorly affects the most vulnerable
countries in this
Global South
we need more diplomacy and as a
Secretary General said
the Black Sea grain initiative is a sign
of Hope to address global concerns on
such harmful consequences and to display
the ground for dialogue can and must be
found
in the first place for the renewal of
the Black Sea grain initiative and for
the street establishment of a nuclear
safe Zone around zaporija nuclear
PowerPoint
we have also asked for a stronger United
Nations we are asking for our more
democratic representative transparent
United Nations because the United
Nations can do more involving more
countries of the world
because after the second World War
from the Second World War II today the
world has changed a great deal and that
is why we need to involve many countries
in this reform Mr President
the data tax to Ukrainian people into
Critical infrastructures with
devastating humanitarian costs are
completely inaccessible and most
immediately
stop
we want to work for peace we are not
against the Russian citizens we are
in favor democracy in favor Freedom we
want to respect
Europe the international Roots this is
our engagement for this we are strongly
involved in defense of Ukraine but we
want to achieve peace peace with Justice
Justice freedom
and Independence okay thank you very
much
I thank his Excellency Mr tayani for his
statement and I now give the floor to
his Excellency Mr Osmani Mr Foreign
Affairs of North Macedonia
thank you Mr President the your
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
I am grateful to Maltese presidency for
the opportunity to address the U.N
security Council today as we mark one
year since the beginning of the
full-scale invasion on territory of
Ukraine
this unprovoked and brutal war of
aggression by the Russian Federation
against Ukraine is a blatant violation
of international law and all principles
enshrined in the U.N Charter and above
all the values of humanity
let me reaffirm the outset or support to
the sovereignty Independence and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
both in my national capacity and later
on in my capacity as chairman in office
of the osce for 2023 I had the
opportunity to visit to visit Ukraine
and places that have been affected by
the war and attacks made by the military
forces of the Russian Federation
I saw firsthand the human suffering
destruction and other consequences of
this senseless war of aggression
must indiscriminate strikes on civilian
sites persist people continue to die and
suffer Russia has continued to conduct
strikes in urban areas leaving civilians
and cities without access to basic human
needs
the finding and investigation so far in
the various cities attacked in Ukraine
lead to the conclusion that war crimes
and crimes against humanity have been
committed the magnitude of committed
sexual abuse and violence against women
and girls is of grave concern as well
the perpetrators of these crimes and
violations of international human rights
and international humanitarian law must
be held accountable and brought to
Justice
in my capacity as chairman Office of the
osc I have already underscored on many
occasions and here today I would like to
put emphasis again on the osc Moscow
mechanism as an important Source invoked
with the aim to establish the facts and
circumstances of possible cases of war
crimes and crimes against humanity in
order to presenting it to the relevant
accountability mechanisms as well as to
the international courts the second
report issued recently confirms the Air
Force said Mr President we fully support
the investigation launched by the ICC
prosecutor aimed at looking into war
crimes and crimes against humanity
committed in the territory of Ukraine
previously we have also welcomed the
international court of justice
provisional measures ordering Russia to
suspend military operations immediately
making full use and ensuring sustainable
funding of existing human rights
mechanisms is also crucial in support of
the accountability processes North
Macedonia believes that we should make
better use of the work and information
gathered by special procedures of the
Human Rights Council in order to
investigate violation and abuses of
Human Rights and related crimes in the
context of the war of aggression against
Ukraine in conclusion in the coming
period it will be particularly important
to curtail any political process that
can undermine the accountability for
gross violations committed we must do
our outmost to ensure access to justice
for the victims of human rights
violation in this senseless aggression
by the Russian Federation
our motto for North Macedonia so I see
chairpersonship is it's about people we
owe it to them to restore peace
immediately we call on the Russian
Federation to stop the war we reiterate
our demand for the immediate cessation
of the military aggression against
Ukraine as well as for the full and
immediate withdrawal of its forces and
military equipment from Ukraine's
territory we have to bring back the
peace and the accountability must
Prevail I thank you
I thank his excellent Mr Spanish for his
statement I now give the floor to his
Excellency Mr Jose Manuel Alvarez
Foreign Affairs European union and
cooperation of Spain
thank you very much Madam president for
organizing this meeting today marks
one year since the tragic start of the
illegal occupation and violation by
Russia against Ukraine in flagrant
violation of international law and the
principles of the U.N Charter the very
existence of Ukraine is at stake as well
as peace and the most basic principles
of the UN Charter
this violation is even more unacceptable
as it comes from a permanent member of
this Security Council
the body to which the UN Charter convert
confers the key responsibility of
maintaining International Peace and
security
and of safeguarding the purposes and
principles of the United Nations
everyday Russian troops remain in the
Sovereign and independent territory of
Ukraine
undermines this remit
Spain fully supports the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of Ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
Spain like many other who others who
have spoken here today and in the
general assembly of the United Nations
is calling for the immediate complete
and unconditional withdrawal of all the
military forces of the Russian
Federation from the entire Ukrainian
territory and a return to their
internationally recognized borders there
is no argument no argument whatsoever to
justify this aggression moreover we
express our most categoric condemnation
of the
indiscriminate shelling by Russia
against key civilian infrastructure and
Targets this is an unacceptable
violation of international humanitarian
law
thousands of civilians Ukrainian
civilians have been identified and have
died as a result of the war and more
than 14 million are displaced there are
alarming signs of massive violations of
human rights of the Ukrainian population
those who are responsible for these very
serious acts must be held accountable
Spain will fully unreservedly support
that
and the use of the veto by the Russian
Federation is keeping the security
Council from exercising its primary
function as a guarantor of International
Peace and security no country should
have the capacity to float this right
for its own purposes as if it were a
blank check to violate international law
without any consequence this veto
however does not keep the International
Community from reacting yesterday the
general assembly spoke out quite clearly
on this issue reiterating its call for
wash Russia to withdraw from
the entirety of Ukrainian territory and
also the general assembly reaffirmed its
commitment to the independence unity and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine and
called for a just and Lasting peace in
respect of the UN Charter and
international law
that is why we are here today in the
security Council we are not just facing
war in Ukraine and in Europe the
unilateral action of Russia is also an
attack against the most basic norms and
principles governing relations among
states
which are
an absolute condition for the
maintenance of International Peace and
security it is the founding principle of
this organization and therefore we call
for an immediate cessation to aggression
and the withdrawal of Russian troops to
their internationally recognized borders
and respect for the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
we want peace for Ukraine for the
Ukrainian people but also for all of us
who defend the U.N Charter and
international law thank you thank you
Miss Alvarez
his Excellency Minnesota
thank you very much Madam president I
greatly appreciate the opportunity to
participate in this Security Council
debate check yeah holds the highest
number of Ukrainian War refugees per
capita nearly half a million most of
them women and children
we are one of the countries most
affected by the direct consequences of
Russia's unprovoked and unjustified war
of aggression against Ukraine
Russia's cruel full-scale aggression
started one year ago its illegal
annexation of Crimea nine years ago
Russia sees other countries the freedom
their democracy or even the statehood as
nothing but spoils up for grips in its
colonialistic and imperialistic ambition
yet
the independence sovereignty and
territory Integrity of Ukraine within
its International recognized borders is
non-negotiable consequences of Russia's
aggression reach far beyond Europe they
are truly Global the the war in wages
has caused shockwaves for the world
commodity markets threatening to drive
50 million people to the brink of famine
across Africa and other continents
Russia's massive airstrikes deliberately
conducted in densely populated areas are
destroying critical civilian
infrastructure and innocent lives
entire towns and Villages have been
wiped out
the evidence of Russia's atrocities and
ferocious attacks against Ukraine
civilian population including children
is overwhelming
just a few days ago President Putin
announced Russia's suspensions of the
new start treaty for him escalation is
the order of the day
we must collectively stop Russia from
dragging us into the horror seminals to
those of the world wars together we have
to defend the U.N Charter accountability
for all crimes under international law
must be ensured yesterday the United
Nations General Assembly resolution
principles underlying a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine was
adopted by the huge majority of votes
the International Community has spoken
clearly about its strong Wish For Peace
in line with the U.N Charter
the peaceful moral plan presented by
President zelinski is the one to be
built on we stand with you crying from
the outset and we remain committed to
Ukraine's wish for just peace as well as
its undeniable right in line with
article 59 of the UN Charter to defend
itself against the aggression I thank
you
for a statement and I'll give the floor
to his Excellency Mr Gordon grilling
Hardman Minnesota Foreign Affairs and
European Affairs of Croatia
Croatia aligns itself with the statement
of under of the EU and I like to add
some remarks in my national capacity
one year one year ago the Russian
Federation sent more than 100 000 of its
soldiers tanks and warplanes to invade
Ukraine with more to come
Russia's troops marched from the East
and from the north from the neighboring
Belarus in an attempt to break Ukraine's
resistance resistance in one sweet move
this foolscape invasion is ineffective
dramatic escalation of the aggression
that began in 2014
with the Russian occupation of Crimea
and parts of donetsky and the lujansk
regions of Ukraine
this was brought nothing but loss of
life countless injury suffering and
distraction
it also brought with itself series of
atrocities accompanied by targeted
destruction of Civilian infrastructure
and mass displacement of people
accountability for these crimes is
important to provide at least some
comfort and sense of justice to the
victims and their families but it would
also serve as a warning and a
deteriorant to other potential
repetitors
perpetrators
the misery brought upon by the Russian
aggression did not just invite within
the borders of Ukraine its poisons
effects and are felt around the world as
food and energy insecurity become
widespread globally
this deadly War aims not just to conquer
Ukraine and strip it of its independence
it aims to invalidate the Union charter
and the Very tenants of the
international law
it aims to dismantle Global Security and
Usher in an age where brute force and
land grab other accepted Norm Mr
President
the Russian army invaded Ukraine not the
other way around nothing can hide that
obvious fact
although each country assembled here at
the United Nations has its own concerns
and aspirations
and tolerance to its different friends
for help
in this war there is the only one side
we can stand on the side protecting the
right of a country to defend itself
it is our duty to support this just
cause not so long ago Croatia was a
victim to a very similar War
with almost the same pretext and cynical
justification
in that difficult situation every help
mattered even if it amounted to Mere
acknowledgment
of the enduring tragedy even it was just
what a recognize the victimization
one such resolution acknowledging the
tragedy and Injustice thrown upon
Ukraine was adopted over hamling
yesterday by the U.N General Assembly
with some exceptions
the world continues to support Ukraine
as well as self-defense of its people
after a year they are not getting tired
so shall not be in our support
however
we do not accept normalization of this
grill or deliberately targeting
civilians Russia started this war and
Russia is the only one that can stop it
by removing its troops from Ukraine
until such moment comes Croatia will
continue continue to stand by and with
Ukraine and its people its independence
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
within internationally recognized
borders we admire
The Bravery a Dignity of ukrainians
defending their country and their homes
and we owe them gratitude for standing
for the crucial principles of the UN
Charter and rules-based international
order thank you
I think his Excellency Mr radman for his
statement and I now give his the floor
to his Excellency Mr urma's Friend Salu
Minister of Foreign Affairs of Estonia
thank you
Mr President
Estonia is a neighbor of aggressor State
Russia and this war has impacted my
country significantly we have received
tens of thousands of Ukrainian refugees
during the course of War we have been
under systematic cyber attacks coming
from Russia
Russia has been waging its full-scale
brutal unprovoked and can a soil war of
aggression against Ukraine for 12 months
now kremlin's goal to raise a sovereign
and Democratic Ukraine from the map has
not changed after a year of courageous
fight Ukraine deserves peace more than
ever however it can't be a peace at all
costs we need just and Lasting peace in
full Conformity with the Yuan Charter
peace that upholds and reinforces
rules-based international order with the
U.N and its core
is that prevents the use of force to
redraw International borders and these
are exactly the same parameters that are
overwhelming majority of the U.N member
states voted
foreign the UN General Assembly
resolution yesterday
the U.N membership firmly supports a
comprehensive just and Lasting piece in
Ukraine that rests on international law
and the U.N Charter Ukrainian peace plan
is based on the same Universal values
and principles and and I therefore call
upon the UN membership to support
president zaranski's ten point peace
plan
article 51 of the U.N Charter grants
every country a right to self-defense
and we need collectively to ensure that
Ukraine can defend itself against
aggressor
we have seen the heinous atrocities that
Russia has committed and unfortunately
still is committing today in Ukraine
this must stop and this is the reason
why estonia's military aid so Ukraine
has reached one percent of our GDP
and
we want Sovereign Ukraine to survive
this brutal aggression and win because
then peace and Justice will be
established
we call All Peoples of world to rise any
support to Ukraine
third in order to achieve lasting peace
full accountability must be insured it
includes Our obligation to discredit
complete aggression as an instrument of
international relations we owe it to the
thousands of ukrainians being killed
rapes and forcibly displaced to hold
Russia's political and Military
leadership to account for the crime of
aggression therefore an international
special Tribunal for the crime of
aggression in Ukraine within the U.N
system must be established we cannot let
Mr Putin hide in the judicial loophole
President Putin time will come and you
will sit on the Tribunal
it is high time to learn from the past
the horrors of War we are witnessing
today are the tragic consequences of the
fact that the atrocity crimes committed
by the Soviet Union during the second
world war including against my country
and my people were left unpunished Not
only would a tribunal serve Justice to
the victims of this horrendous crime it
also serves as a deterrent and can help
to prevent future conflicts
finally today on the 105th anniversary
of my country as soon as Declaration of
Independence our independence day my
thoughts are with our brave countrymen
and women who fought for our freedom and
Independence and yet I also pray for
Ukraine and ukrainians who are the
bravest people I know Ukraine is not
only defending its country people and
right to exist but Ukraine is also
defending common values of United
mankind International legal order and
the U.N Charter
rises from truth Russian Federation is a
terrorist regime which commits genocide
against Ukrainian people world needs to
recognize that thank you
I thank his Excellency Mr orenzalo for
his statement there are no more names
inscribed on the list of speakers
the meeting is adjourned